all the lawyers
oh
it's
always incognito
thank you
now
good morning everyone
it being 9 a.m
i am going to
we are opening the public hearings today
for the criminal justice and public
safety committee i would ask everyone to
please rise and join us in the pledge of
allegiance
yes they are
and with that i am going to open the
public hearing on h.b 1636
and the criminal justice and public
safety committee calls representative
john burt
thank you mr chairman and fine committee
members
last year we passed this
out of the house went to the senate
and
and there was a oops
the other side of the wall
and
there was an amendment attached to it
and uh sadly the governor vetoed this
bill
the governor
has said and the other side said as long
as there's no attachments they will pass
this so i hope we can
out to pass this bill
bottom line this is a housekeeping bill
currently
if you have a concealed new hampshire
concealed carry license
you can carry a gun
on a snowmobile or a four-wheeler
now you're going to hear testimony i'm
assuming if they show up
that
there's going to be a
accidental discharges
if this passes
well i'll tell you right now most people
that i know
that ride snowmobiles and four-wheelers
carry a gun and i've never heard of an
accidental discharge
because most people don't know that
there's a tiny little law in fishing
game that goes against constitutional
carry
that says you can't carry while you're
on a snowmobile
or
a four-wheeler
i'm also told that fish and game will
not enforce this
because they were told by the a.g that
if you enforce this if you you know
give somebody a ticket for carrying a
gun on a snowmobile or a four-wheeler
it's going to be thrown out of court
and so they've been told not to enforce
this so this is really just a
housekeeping bill it's just to clean the
language out so that way constitutional
carry in new hampshire
is constitutional carry in new hampshire
you should have a right
any vehicle you're in to carry a gun
without a license
and again if you have a concealed carry
license today like i do
and i was just on a snowmobile
guess what i'm carrying
that's the way it is but if you don't
have a concealed carry license because
you don't need one for constitutional
carry
then fish and game can
cite you against this law that is on the
books which i'm hoping to repeal
and again fish and game was told not to
do that but we still need to clean the
language up so that way everything is
clean
when it comes to our laws
i want to thank you for your allowing me
to speak and i hope you vote yes on this
bill
there being no questions from the
committee thank you for your testimony
thank you
we now call representative greg huff
thank you mr chairman and thank you
honorable members of the criminal
justice and public safety committee
i am
in favor of this bill i request that you
give it an otp to pass and my testimony
will be very brief article 2a
of the new hampshire constitution the
bearing of arms all persons have the
right to keep and bear arms in defense
of themselves their families their
property and the state
thank you for hearing my testimony i'll
take any questions
there being no questions thank you for
your testimony
we now call alan rice gunnos of america
good morning mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is alan
rice i am a resident of bedford new
hampshire and i'm here on behalf of gun
owners of america
we strongly support representative
burt's bill we were a strong supporter
of constitutional carry
when it was enacted in 2017 we've now
had almost five years
of
residents and visitors to new hampshire
carrying guns loaded and concealed on
their person
in their cars in their pickup trucks and
on their boats without a license um the
outlier is as representative burt stated
an antiquated fish and game law that
requires a person
to obtain a license to carry a concealed
and loaded pistol or revolver
or even an openly
carried pistol or revolver on a snow
machine or an atv
it's inconsistent with our
constitutional carry law
it violates article 2a as representative
huff pointed out and on behalf of gun
owners of america we would urge the
criminal justice and public safety
committee to vote house bill 1636 ought
to pass without any amendments and if
there are any questions i'll be happy to
answer them
there being no questions we appreciate
the testimony thank you thank you sir
the committee now calls lauren lepage
from the national rifle association
morning my name is lauren lepage i am a
resident of sanford maine but i am the
new hampshire state director for the
national rifle association
um we are here in strong support of this
bill we supported it last year as well
we thank representative bert for
submitting this bill
i will be very brief and will submit
electronic testimony for the committee
um but i do just want to echo we see
this as a common sense cleanup measure
just to make permit less carry
consistent across the board and
certainly you shouldn't give up your
right to self-defense just because you
chose to recreate on an off-train
vehicle versus some other sort of
vehicle so i'm happy to take any
questions but like i said i will submit
electronic testimony to the committee as
well
there be no questions thank you for your
testimony
the committee now calls penny dean
and cold so i apologize if i
not copeland just fighting
i'm an attorney i'm licensed in maine
new hampshire massachusetts and i'm
admitted to several federal courts as
well and i'm just
calling it or testifying here to say
that this is really common sense
that depict on a person because of their
choice of transportation and
particularly women
i think of women i've had several
surgeries i still need a new ankle yet
and i need to be able to defend myself
in any situation and by any mode of
transportation but as the committee
consider that in the fact that
you can't always choose your method of
transportation
and you certainly can't choose where the
bad guys are and so being a woman and
being unfortunately i never thought it'd
be but somewhat disabled in
transportation somewhat i need to be
able to defend myself and i'd last the
committee to give us that opportunity
thank you
happy to answer any questions by the way
there be no questions thank you for your
testimony
is there anyone else who hasn't signed
up but wishes to testify on this bill
there being none i hereby close the
hearing on hb 1636
and at this time i'm going to open an
executive session on hb 1636.
anyone wish to make a motion
state your motion please
thank you mr chairman i make a motion
about to pass
is there a second
second
seconded motion made by representative
burt out to pass
seconded
by representative wallace
does anyone wish to make a discussion
yes mr chairman
go ahead thank you mr chairman
this really is a housekeeping bill
we have constitutional carry
there's this law and fishing game that
really needs to be repealed they can't
enforce it or they won't because they
know what's going to happen if they go
to court
so
i know the ag and i and many other gun
owners would like to have this cleaned
up
so that way we have a true
constitutional carry in new hampshire so
i hope you will vote yes
when the vote comes thank you mr
chairman
now representative wallace he was to
speak to your second
no
does anyone else wish to speak
there being no one else wishing to speak
i'll now put this to the vote
the clerk will call the vote
vice chairman roy yes representative
welch yes
representative rhodes yes representative
byrd
representative greene
clark votes yes representative testament
representative true
yes
representative pratt
representative marston
yes
representative harriet gathright no
representative panolakis no
representative o'hearn
representative bordenay
no
representative muse
representative newman
representative bolden
representative
connolly
no
representative klein knight
representative bradley no
chairman abbas
chair votes yes
with 10 years six nays and four no votes
motion passes
i hereby close the executive session on
hb 1636
and
we will be in recess until 9 45.
will there be minority
majority reports
will there be a minority report on that
no idea
over here
here
viewers
do you have a suitcase
you missed the purple deck
it was quick
um
you got an orange cone
we could have met in uh
you don't have one not this side do you
is this one
okay no no
yes
uh
that's a good questions
oh
thank you very much
um just keep an eye
i know
all
hear right
excuse me i'm somebody special excuse me
get up get out of my way i'm sorry
test
is this on
is
i might be asleep knock on the door
before
david's there too yeah
according to what we heard yesterday you
can
take one
you can ask the chair the chair will you
please come here and address a proper
issue
an issue not a problem
here's some
yes
can only do one
he doesn't have
i know
so
um
you
putting it back
catch as much
how are you
it's been so hard
oh
shut up
this
i have to rearrange everything if you're
going to stick somebody in
so
he said he was
this
right
i'm sorry what did you say dick i wasn't
listening to you
because people who are coming in from
california to testify
you know they have to be here by
11 30
otherwise they flew in for nothing
dick you want a donut i bought five
bucks a donut five bucks you're sure
pretty soon there's what you're six
dollars
down there you haven't signed in
nobody fights as needed you
you are important
i'm thinking about self-letting some of
this space you know airbnb and something
you know
i
no violence
violence is out of style
these tables
at least
is
tuesdays
give me the big
all right
i know
you know
uh
um
oh
it's not a perfect process
i think the big difference
we actually heard
yes
vice
mental chairmanship
oh
i don't think there's a
very very difference
okay
remember when i is
four years
there you go
what
that was
a day
they said oh no you're over in rex hall
walked away no comments
okay
is
i'm so nervous
david
um
great
oh
i
at this time we'll now open the public
hearing on house bill 1668 requiring a
background check prior to any commercial
firearm sales
the committee now calls the honorable
catherine rogers
thank you mr chairman um first of all i
mean no disrespect by wearing my hat i
just find myself recently in a position
of
being follicly challenged and it's very
cold so
i apologize and there's no disrespect
meant by that
um thank you members of the committee
and mr chairman
my name is catherine rogers i represent
merrimack district 28 which is the east
side of concord
and we happily welcome you to our city
every day
house bill 1668 is a simple bill
it fills a loophole that currently
exists by requiring commercial
advertised firearm sales or transfers to
be subject to a criminal background
check
if that does not happen the seller faces
a misdemeanor penalty for each violation
the language is clear and specific
it makes an exception for sales or
transfers between friends and families
this is not an overreach by government
it's a public safety measure to keep
more guns out of the hands of those who
we all agree shouldn't have them people
like felons and domestic abusers
we may be lucky enough to have avoided
the spotlight of any national tragedy
with any mass shooting so far in our
state however we're not immune to
violence
we do have firearms-related violence in
new hampshire
new hampshire is also a net exporter of
guns and the substantial percentage of
our firearms have a short time to crime
that is the percentage of guns recovered
in a crime within two years of original
sale
a strong indicator of gun trafficking
according to data collected from the gun
trafficking statistics from the bureau
of alcohol tobacco firearms and
explosives
new hampshire exported 18.3 guns per
hundred thousand inhabitants whereas the
national average was 14.1 and 29.3
percent of new hampshire's firearms have
a short time to crime the national
average was 22.6
you will likely hear the argument that
this bill will only affect law-abiding
citizens
because criminals don't follow the law
anyway
my response is that why don't we all
just pack up and go home
maybe that's a good thing for some of us
to think
what's good in passing laws when
criminals don't follow any of the laws
laws impose restrictions on the behavior
of only those who follow them
laws therefore only hurt law-abiding
citizens
every law could be refuted with this
paradox and societies would swiftly
descend into anarchy laws against rape
murder and theft for example are rarely
followed by rapists murderers and
thieves but the fact that such people
exist in society is the reason these
laws are there in the first place
you may hear also that the second
amendment is sacred and should never be
regulated under any circumstance we know
that the supreme court has ruled that it
can be regulated and we know that that
same constitution
also grants the right to free speech and
yet we do not have the right to yell
fire in a crowded theater
and while we're talking about the
constitution we also have a constitution
that provides for a free and fair
election
but we do ask people to identify
themselves when they go to the polls
more and more so we ask for more
identity so that's regulated everything
in the constitution can be regulated
reasonably house bill 1668's a simple
bill but it merely requires anyone
selling a firearm at an in-state gun
show flea market or via online
solicitation or classified ad to get a
background check
it's constitutional and it's a
regulation that fits in with the beliefs
and the majority of our population
close to 80 percent of the population
supports this kind of regulation
i ask you to look at this bill
thoughtfully and vote ought to pass and
i thank you so much for your time today
thank you representative
the committee now calls cindy white
representative muse
yes i had a question for representative
rogers
you're recognized
representative rogers is this bill uh
fundamentally the same as hb
from the 2000 from the 2020 session
yes it is representative muse
thank you
representative you're excused
thank you my name is cindy white i'm an
attorney from hopkinton and i'm here in
support of this bill
david ray connolly was barred from
owning a firearm because of his criminal
record but he bought a gun over the
internet with no background check and he
used it to massacre eight people in
texas
dylann roof was prohibited by law from
buying a gun but was allowed to buy one
because the background check was not
completed within three business days he
used that gun to massacre nine people at
a charleston church during bible study
these cases happened in other states but
they could just as easily have happened
here because of gaping loopholes in our
gun safety laws
keeping guns out of the hands of
dangerous persons is critical we know
that it's risky to allow felons domestic
views abusers and other prohibited
persons
to have access to guns
in 34 of mass shootings between 2009
the gunman was legally barred from
possessing firearms
studies show that stronger background
check laws are associated with
significantly lower rates of firearms
homicides and suicides
many people misunderstand the current
law and believe that the federal law
requires background checks in all cases
but it does not
the federal brady law has been very
successful
it has blocked sales to millions of
dangerous people who are not legally
allowed to possess guns
but but it applies only to sales by
federally licensed firearms dealers
because of that limitation an estimated
22 percent of all gun sales
millions each year take place with no
background check many at gun chosen over
the internet
hb 1668 would help close this loophole
enacting a state background check
requirement should be an easy choice
it's a win-win situation
it will enhance public safety and save
lives while respecting the rights of
reasonable law-abiding gun owners
nobody should want to allow guns to get
into the hands of dangerous people and
almost nobody does
background check requirements are
supported by 97 percent of americans
and 94 percent of granite state staters
including 90 percent of gun owners
the bill would also close a second
gaping hole in the federal law the
charleston loophole by requiring
completion of the background check
before a commercial firearm sale
federal law does not require this
under the law a licensed firearm dealer
may proceed with the sale of a firearm
after three business days even if the
required background check has not been
completed and there's been no
confirmation that the buyer is legally
permitted to buy a gun
as a result people who are prohibited
from law by purchasing a gun are often
allowed to buy one just because the
background check has not been finished
the best known example of this is dylann
roof but there are many cases like this
that happen every day
requiring a completed background check
would not delay most gun sales most
background checks are finished very
quickly in only about 11 percent of
cases does the nics need more
information and it is important that
they be allowed to get that information
time to get it
of the cases in 2017 in which nics
delayed its answer to get more
information
it later determined that more than six
thousand
of those people were legally prohibited
from buying a firearm
unfortunately in almost 5000 of those
cases the seller allowed the prohibited
person to buy a weapon because the
background check was not completed
within three business days
this committee is charged with
protecting public safety
it should not allow partisan divides and
heated rhetoric against gun laws to
interfere with its duty to somberly
assess this bill
hb 1668 does not prevent anyone who is
legally permitted to have a gun from
getting one
but it does strengthen the law to help
assure that dangerous persons who are
not legally allowed to have guns do not
get one
for those reasons i ask you to vote for
this bill
could you please submit your written
testimony thank you
thank you the witness is excused
the committee now calls joe hannon
gun owners in new hampshire
good morning committee uh thank you for
having me here today my name is joe
hannon i'm the vice president for gun
owners of new hampshire and we ask you
today to please itl this bill this is
not the first time we've heard it as
you've already as you're well aware
it is
it has changed slightly since previous
generations of the bill it does seem to
allow more exceptions than the last
version i recall
however
[Music]
it does say if the status of either
parties eligibility to own or possess a
firearm cannot be ascertained the
transaction shall be completed through a
licensed firearms deal
you know the background check system is
not 100 either we've heard of mistakes
we've heard some people say that there
were people who had not been reported to
the next system because of errors by
either the police department the air
force was one example where someone
was a danger who was not reported by the
air force and was able to commit a crime
with
getting those firearms the three-day
waiting period is something that
if you heard testimony that it
if you don't get uh
an answer back in three days you're
automatically allowed to get your
firearm
you know it is long enough to do the job
most almost every mistake that i've
heard of and and you will hear of that
the person got a firearm after three
days without being denied after three
days was due to an error now do we give
someone 10 days to not make us an hour a
week two months
i don't think it's going to make a
difference these have all been examples
that really have not would not have been
prevented by this law whatsoever
if you look at people buying firearms on
the internet without doing a background
check from a dealer that is already
against the law firearm sealers are not
allowed to do a sale over the internet
without a background check to an
in-state other licensed dealer
that's already illegal so all these
examples you've heard were either errors
by people in the system that we're
trying to
make stronger
or
were illegal acts so i please ask you to
i tell this bill and i'd be happy to
take any questions
thank you very much thank you
witness is
the excused calls representative deborah
altschiller
thank you mr chairman i was going to
read off my phone but
even with my glasses i can't see it that
well so i beg your indulgence for me
having my computer and you will all have
a copy of this in your email
thank you very much for hearing my
testimony today
while federal law requires background
checks for all gun sales by licensed gun
dealers
it does not require background checks
for guns sold by unlicensed sellers
like non-dealers who sell guns online or
at gun shows this loophole enables
people with felony convictions domestic
abuse restraining orders
and other people with prohibiting
histories to buy guns with no questions
asked
the loophole should be closed to require
background checks on all gun sales
not just on the sale of firearms from
licensed gun dealers
on the east coast people can buy a
firearm in new hampshire and maine
without a background check
vermont massachusetts rhode island
connecticut
new jersey new york
delaware pennsylvania maryland virginia
and north carolina
all require background checks on firearm
sales
we have made ourselves an oasis
for people looking to get around a
background check requirement in their
purchase of a firearm
earlier this morning i did a search on a
popular firearms resale website
and for less than fifteen hundred
dollars i can have a firearm by the end
of the day
requiring background checks on all gun
sales is proven to reduce gun violence
state laws requiring background checks
for all handgun sales by point of sale
check
are associated with lower firearm
homicide rates lower firearm suicide
rates
and lower firearm trafficking
when connecticut passed a law requiring
background checks
both for a handgun purchase permit and
the point of sale its firearm homicide
rate decreased by 40 percent and its
firearm suicide rate decreased by 15
percent
every year
34 000 americans take their own life
leaving behind thousands of friends and
family members to navigate the tragedy
of their loss
suicide is the 10th leading cause of
death among adults in the united states
and third leading cause of death among
adolescents in new hampshire
firearm death is the third leading cause
of death
suicidal thoughts and behaviors are both
damaging
and dangerous and therefore considered a
psychiatric emergency
someone experiencing these thoughts
should
seek immediate
assistance from a health or mental
health research care provider
research provided by nami new hampshire
has found
that about 90 percent of individuals who
die by suicide are experiencing a mental
health crisis
oftentimes undiagnosed
untreated
experiencing this mental health crisis
is the number one risk factor for
suicide
more women than men attempt suicide but
men are four times more likely to die by
suicide
and people under the age of 24 or above
the age of 65 are at a higher risk for
suicide
we have endured and are still dealing
with a worldwide pandemic
that has been a national trauma
the weights in our community hospitals
for mental health services are weeks at
a time
and should show us in no uncertain terms
that the current overall mental health
of our state is not okay
requiring background checks to acquire
the most deadly means to harm oneself
or others is the absolute
least we can do
this is a suicide prevention bill in my
opinion
and i urge the committee to vote ought
to pass thank you for your time
thank you the witness is excused
the committee now calls rusan chester
thank you committee chair thank you
chair members
i can't get this down i'm just going to
go like this
um just wanted to say a quick with
regards to
mental health and the sale of firearms i
am opposed to this bill
opposed to it passing uh for the for the
mere
fact of um
i
have the right to carry i have concealed
carry so
um but i had to wait three days for my
for because i
i don't know i don't know why it
ended up taking three days for my pass
the fir the second time the first time i
got it in three hours the second time it
took three days so there is a problem
what i what i want to point out is that
um a federal background check
i don't think is as good as what our
dealers are doing individually my when i
went to sig and um
they actually
interviewed me
they sat down with me i still i did the
federal background check too
um
because of the weapon that i wanted to
purchase however
i think they did a better job than what
the federal government did because the
federal government
for whatever reason didn't allow me to
have my federal license and or have it
approved for three days where they were
able to do it the first time
with regards to mental health the bottom
line is is that we're worried about
suicide being the number one cause and
because of a mental health crisis then
let's take the money that it would cost
to keep to put this in place and put it
towards our mental health and our
suicide prevention
thank you
thank you you are excused
we now call alan rice in america
good morning mr chairman
members of the committee for the record
my name is alan rice and i am a resident
of bedford new hampshire and i'm here on
behalf of gun owners of america
we are on record as being opposed to
house bill 1668
which is a
major intrusion into private activities
between private parties
this isn't about commercial sales this
is about
someone selling lending
gifting a gun to a friend family member
or neighbor
and forcing all those sales through
licensed firearms dealers
over the last few years and this
committee passed last year legislation
to address that
we've seen a lot of delays with the
check system
forcing tens of thousands more sales
through that check system
would certainly
make the problem worse
there is no loophole
um federal law actually covers some of
the things that the supporters of this
bill are concerned about
we're not exporting guns because that's
against the law
to sell a gun privately the two parties
to the transaction need to be a resident
of the same state so there's no way
someone from massachusetts or maine or
any other state
can answer a classified ad and come to
new hampshire and buy a gun
that's against federal law and there's
federal law enforcement that
aggressively prosecute those violations
there's no loophole
this bill is a major
solution in search of a non-existent
problem and we would urge this committee
to vote
house bill 1668 in expedient to
legislate and i'd be happy to entertain
any questions from the committee members
representative klein knight you're
recognized for a question thank you so
much chair and thank you for taking my
question are you aware as this bill is
currently written it would allow for
people to gift guns within family
members
well
i kind of expected a question like that
and
my attorney pointed me out to section
one commercial sale means a transfer of
ownership including
not limited to a sale exchange or gift
says gift
representative
representative klein knight you
recognize for a follow-up question
before you ask the question let me just
remind the members of the committee that
we are not permitted to debate
any witness who testifies before the
committee we ask questions in order to
gather information about the bill
thank you so much chair um are you aware
that the the sponsor is in fact aware of
of that concern and then did amend this
bill so it would loosely define that
language and that in fact that you still
could be gifted a gun by your family
member
representative what i'm aware of is i
spent quite a few hours with our inside
council being briefed on this bill and
he tells me this is a gross overreach
it's an anti-gun bill designed to chill
private activities between friends
family members and neighbors he tells me
that this bill will not solve any of the
problems that you claim to need to
that need to be solved but it will put
otherwise law-abiding people at risk of
arrest and criminal prosecution
thank you for your testimony the witness
is excused
thank you mr chairman the committee now
calls lauren lepage national liberal
association
good morning my name is lauren lepage
i'm a resident of stanford maine and i'm
the state director for the national
rifle association here in new hampshire
i will be brief and will um
like as in my previous testimonies
submit something in writing to the
committee
just wanted to point out that we are in
opposition to this legislation
this legislation does
call for background checks on the
commercial sale of firearms but it is
duplicative federal law already requires
you if you are engaged in the business
of selling firearms or trying to make a
livelihood
that you require a federal license and
regardless of where any sort of transfer
takes place as a licensee an ffl you are
required to do an in-person background
check under federal law which is um
like i said duplicative and unnecessary
so for that main reason
my written testimony will be a little
more detailed
we're in opposition to the bill and i'm
happy to take any questions
thank you for your testimony
we now call penny dean
good morning members of the committee my
name is penny dean
from concord new hampshire and i would
ask that the bill be itled
and the first thing i would suggest we
hear the term loophole again and again
and again
there's online dictionaries there's
webster's dictionaries the term loophole
is a very well defined term
and it means a failure to avoid the
scope of a law
18 usc did not intend to capture all of
these things that people complain about
there is no loophole in the law the law
works perfectly as it was designed to do
so when they talk about a loophole there
isn't any
secondly the things that most the people
are complaining about
some of them are already illegal and
they can still be prosecuted but what we
see happening more and more even with
the current check system is that people
who are lawfully able to
and should be able to have guns are
denied because of glitches in the system
not the opposite not to say the opposite
doesn't happen
but when one person said for fifteen
hundred dollars i could have a gun by
the end of the day
that might be too late if you've got a
domestic violence restraining order
against a person
um you could be like the woman in new
jersey who waited and waited and waited
she's now dead
so the bottom line is being able to have
access to a life-saving self-defense
tool almost immediately for a
law-abiding person is the way it's
supposed to be
and the way it should continue to be
we hear statistics from some people that
97 percent of gun owners support these
type of checks and here's what i would
respectfully ask this committee whenever
witnesses tell you something like that
ask them to produce the study
i'm going to suggest there is no such
study i keep up on a lot of statistics
and firearm owners and i've never seen
an academic
honest study that comes to those
conclusions
so in short this is a bill
that is a problem
it's going to disenfranchise a lot of
gun owners
it's going to make criminals out of
people who couldn't believe that
something's illegal when you give your
wife a firearm for christmas now you got
a problem you just broke the law there's
just a lot of unintended consequences
from this bill
and i don't see a problem that needs to
be solved
and so
the bottom line is the reverse is true
you more than likely see people having
to spend hundreds and thousands of
dollars and wait for long periods of
time when they're wrongfully denied a
firearm
and i'm happy to answer any questions
representative klein knight you are
recognized for a question thank you
chair um thank you so much for taking my
question do you know with 100 certainty
if the woman in new jersey already had a
gun
i don't know i i believe every newspaper
article said that she did not but i do
not know her personally and i didn't
know her personally but there's been
other cases where people were waiting
for firearms or not able to get firearms
and had problems in the domestic
violence context representative klein
knight you're recognized for a follow-up
question thank you chair so um i i do
hear a major concern with domestic
violence and as a domestic violence
champion myself i take it very serious
so when you say a lot of
women are waiting
to protect themselves do you have a
rough number of that exactly how many
women actually apply for guns and then
are waiting for them it depends on the
state
because what you're see or what this
bill rather suggests doing
is having the type of gun control
legislation that's available in several
let's say massachusetts which is not
known as the last bastion of freedom so
i don't think there are the other thing
is that women
initially when they are abused and leave
an abusive relationship i don't know
that they're signing up on sheets and
coming out and making national surveys
to say how many so i don't know i that
number i know from the number that call
me and those are that's a select group
that's not a statistically valid sample
that it's more than there should be
thank you the witness is excused
at this time we'll now close the public
hearing on house bill
at this time we will now open the
executive session on house bill
representative burke do you wish to be
recognized
to make a motion
yes mr chairman and thank you
i make a recommendation of itl of 1668.
second
that's been seconded by representative
roy
representative bert do you wish to speak
to the motion
yes mr chairman and thank you
um
we've seen this bill many many times
you know there are small small changes
this time but it's still
the same
bill
you know per se
that we've itled in the past
it just isn't going to fix anything
because you take a family member that
wants to give a
firearm to their grandson
you know that should be allowed
you know without a background because
that's what current law is and it's
always worked
you know i
i think criminals are going to
be criminals you know regardless of what
we pass you know look at chicago
and you know they
you know more laws is not going to fix
some problem areas
where criminals just keep going to
certain parts of cities and just buy
illegal guns this is not going to fix
that
so this is just against law-abiding
citizens in my eyes and that's why i
support the itl and i hope you do too
thank you
representative newman
thank you mr chair
i just want to bring
to the attention of the committee that
this is the
criminal justice
and public safety committee
we hear a lot of bills about
guns
we hear
arguments
that say to
keep to protect a person's right
to defend themselves
we can't
we can't put any regulation
on the second amendment
of the constitution
or even
the amen the
article in the new hampshire
constitution
that
also is regulated
and the reason i brought up
the fact that the second half of the
name of this committee was public safety
is that we seldom hear about
article 3 of the new hampshire
constitution
and in that article it says
when men enter into a state of society
they surrender some of their national
rights their natural rights to that
society
in order to ensure the protection of
others
we seldom hear about our constitutional
requirement
to provide
for the safety of others
not only with guns
but also with things like health and
others
i heard some testimony today
about we can't let the feds do the
background check
because they can't do it right the feds
can't do anything right
i'm paraphrasing of course and maybe
there's a little bit of hyperbole in
there
but the fact is that
the background check works we've heard
testimony
about the percentages of people
who are prohibited persons
and they're prohibited because we can
regulate the second amendment and we
have regulated it
now it will only last until the supreme
court
says
that they're unconstitutional because
i believe that we have to follow supreme
court decisions even though i'm not
happy with the current makeup of the
supreme court i don't know what's going
to happen but by god i will fought i
will follow
what they say
so
i think that this is a modest bill
i think it's a modest bill that protects
the citizens of new hampshire and i
think that this bill ought to be passed
and i will oppose
propose the itl
amendment
thank you very much mr chair
representative roy you're recognized
thank you mr chairman
i believe that
my job as a state representative i'm
here for two things to solve problems
and protect the rights of the citizens
of new hampshire
there has been no evidence presented to
this committee that we have a problem
with firearms in this state
therefore i resort to the second reason
i'm here and that's to protect the
rights of the citizens of this state and
i shall do so by voting this bill in
expedient to legislate thank you
representative muse you're recognized
thank you mr chair
i plan once again on
supporting
supporting the bill opposing the itl
recommendation
currently in our state
if what we require is uh anybody who
is uh
buying a firearm commercially from a
dealer is required to go through a
background check process
and
that background check process actually
works pretty well
it makes sure that people who are
subject to protective orders aren't able
to buy firearms it flags people like
felons what it does is it makes sure
that people
who
should not
be owning weapons
aren't able to simply walk into a store
put down a credit card and buy a deadly
weapon what we're talking about doing
here
is actually bringing that same
capability over to a private commercial
sale
so when i put an ad in the newspaper or
i put an ad online
i have absolutely no idea who's going to
answer that ad who's going to walk in
through that door
i have no idea if they're
if they're a veteran if they're a police
officer
or if they're a serial killer that's
killed a dozen people i have absolutely
no way of knowing that and that's one of
the reasons why we need a law like this
this is a huge
gap in public safety
this
this bill
offers us the opportunity to close that
gap and this is something that we should
take advantage of thank you
representative bourdain i know you had
your hand up do you still wish to speak
on the motion
uh thank you
we heard testimony that basically that
if we passed this bill that
we would no longer be able to transfer
firearms from
between family members
i'd like to point out in the bill on
page two
starting
approximately line 30
exceptions this chapter shall not apply
to a non-commercial private cell
transfer or exchangeable firearm between
individuals provided another party to
neither of our transactions
person so
that exception uh
allows the trade of firearms to family
members if they
are qualified to own firearms so um
i'm going to vote to id on the bill
not iddl but support the important thank
you representative boarding can you
repeat the page and line number again
yes
page 2
line 30
on exceptions
so if i could ask it says non-commercial
sales which i i understand that but on
the if you look at the
page 1 lines
11 and 12
is the definition of commercial sales
somebody's asking how would you
interpret in consideration both what you
just read on page 2 lines 30 and page 1
lines 11 and 12.
how do you reconcile those
the exception is clear
i do not i don't do not think that those
types of transactions are disqualified
but wouldn't that apply to
non-commercial sales
sorry wouldn't that apply to
non-commercial sales not commercial
sales where commercial sales a gift i
guess i was asking would apply to
commercial sales but we're talking about
non-commercial sales
okay
representative
klein knight you're recognized
thank you mr chair
my job as a state representative is to
protect domestic violence citizens all
over the state and the mere
inconvenience of getting a third or
fifth gun
out is should be abhorrent that it
outweighs the fact that we should be
protecting lives and we should be caring
more about saving lives than collecting
personal arsenals this does not affect
your right to bear arms at all just your
right to make
suicide attempts more easier murders
more easier so i will be voting against
the itl motion and i urge my colleagues
in the committee to vote this motion
down so another more correct
motion can be made of ought to pass
thank you
representative
conley you mr chairman
one thing that i think has been lost in
this debate thus far is
do people in the state want us to pass
this kind of law and poll after poll
after poll
has shown that new hampshire residents
support this law
and it's not by a plurality or a small
majority it's 88 and above it's 94 if
you count those who somewhat favor
we've heard from the gun lobbyists who
are paid to be here we know what they
think
but
we now know that the broad majority of
new hampshire residents support this
we should pass the bill as it has been
passed we know the governor supported it
before he was against it so i think he
was right the first time we should
oppose the motion make another one pass
the bill thank you
and i'll just speak on this briefly and
for the members who were a member of the
house
last term may have recalled i said this
at the
wealth right to my left over here
that
when we had a similar bill last term
it was presented to us that 99 of sales
are transfers to a person that would be
prohibited under law from possessing a
firearm
99 of those were through either a straw
purchase which means they had
a third party purchase the firearm on
their behalf so they can
get around the background check or they
purchase it illegally in the black
market
where this policy is dealing with the
one percent
so i hear a lot about public safety and
we're the criminal justice public safety
committee
but we're dealing with
one percent of
firearm transactions that we're trying
to prevent not the 99 percent
so i feel this this misses
misses the point with that at least with
respect to that information
so i'll be supporting the
motion of inks being to legislate
i only recognize each member to speak
once
do any members wish to speak who haven't
spoken already
at this time the matter will be put to
put the question
if you're in support of the motion of
inexpediting to legislate
please say yes if you are opposed
please say no the clerk will not call
the roll
vice chairman roy
yes
representative welch
yes representative burt
yes
representative rhodes
representative greene
yes
clark votes yes representative testerman
representative true yes
representative pratt
yes
representative marston
representative harriet gathright no
representative pantalakis no
representative o'hearn
representative bordenay
no
representative muse
representative newman
no
representative bolden
representative conley
representative klein knight no
representative bradley
no
chairman abbas
the chair votes yes
the vote is 11 yays nine nays one not
voting
the motion passes
representative will you be preparing the
majority report
yes mr chairman i will i'll have it in
tonight
would it be a minority report
representative connolly you're taking
responsibility
thank you representative
at this time we will now close the
executive session on house bill 1668.
just quickly before we we begin the next
public hearing
uh
i will be s at this time set up a few
subcommittees
uh the first one is going to be house
bill 1215 that's relative to the
definition of residual amount
in the controlled drug act
that subcommittee will be chaired by
representative roy
and representative wallace
you'll be assigned to that subcommittee
as well
and uh representative welch you'll be
assigned to the subcommittee
representative conley would be assigned
to that subcommittee
and representative bordnay will be on
the subcommittee
i'm also going to
we're going to have a subcommittee for
house bill 1540 it's relative to
recording custodial interrogations
that would be
chaired by representative roy as well
and i'm going to put representative
o'hearn on the subcommittee
representative greene
you're going to be assigned to the
subcommittee
house bill 1540 relative to recording
custodial interrogations
thank you
representative representative welch
you'll also be on the subcommittee
and representative gathering harriet
garth we've been that subcommittee as
well 1540.
and for hb 1266 we're going to have a
subcommittee that would also be chaired
by representative roy
i'm going to have a representative green
and representative
wallace also assigned to that
subcommittee
representative conley you'll be assigned
a subcommittee
on hb 1266
and
we'll put representative klein knight as
well
and just say anyone knows any members of
the committee are always allowed to
attend the subcommittee
meetings and participate just when it
makes the only time they not allowed to
participate when the subcommittee makes
a recommendation
at this time we are now opening the
public hearing on house bill 1310
prohibiting the discharge of a firearm
in the direction of a building
livestock or pets
the committee calls the representative
from
deerfield kevin verville
thank you mr chairman ladies and
gentlemen committee
uh
nice to see you this morning
twice in one year kind of surprised back
again so
this bill is not the bill probably any
of you expected to see coming from me
and i'll tell you why i filed this bill
the phone rings
constituents on the other side
admittedly a good friend
and he's hot
and this guy is is
as calm and steady as any man i've ever
met
and he's about ready to jump out of his
skin
because he had a bad morning
so
it's an old dairy farm
no more dairy
they raised beef head
and
the head were out
he was on the tractor
bringing him basically bringing him back
for breakfast
when he hears an earth-shattering kaboom
that makes him
jump a little bit in the seat of his
tractor because he recognizes the sound
avid hunter avid outdoorsman
and he realizes somebody just took a
shot pretty pretty close to where i am
and the tractor's running so to hear it
like that's a little discerning
and he looks
and here comes the guy across the field
walking essentially towards him
so he jumps off the tractor and
you know inquires as to what might be
going on
and the gentleman explains that he had
been in the tree line turkey hunting
and turkey happened to come by
and he took the shot
challenge is if you stand or sit
this gentleman wasn't
tree-lined and i did that i went out
there i
saw the whole thing and the guy that
took the shot doesn't deny any of this
he was shooting at a turkey
and the backdrop
was a big red barn
with
i don't know 20 to 40
head of beef cattle
out waiting for breakfast
so
my constituent's a reasonable guy
and the hunter says well you know i
didn't do anything wrong so
they call fish and game they call the
police
mission game shows up they interview the
guy you know everything stacks up just
like i told you and fishing games said
yeah you know it's it's a legal shot and
there's nothing we can do
so the guy gets his turkey and off he
goes now
he wasn't within 300 feet of a building
that he didn't have permission to be on
the land because that's the current law
right
but he was shooting
you know when you when you take up a
firearm you're supposed to know your
target and what's beyond it and what was
beyond it was a big red barn and beef
cap and not too far off a guy on his
tractor
and he was shooting in that general
direction so
i don't think that's right
i don't think that that shot should have
ever been taken
but that shot's a legal shot now we're
lucky
right we're lucky this guy was turkey on
he had a shotgun there's no way that
shot was going to make it to those cows
from where he took it okay
nobody disagrees with that my
constituent knows that i know that
probably most of you on this committee
know that
if we close our eyes
and imagine a less experienced hunter
deer hunting that same property
with a rifle
all of a sudden you've got a totally
totally different
set of what's going on
and the law doesn't differentiate
distance between shotgun
and rifle
under these conditions
so it's for that reason i filed this
bill to add part two to make it unlawful
for a person to discharge a firearm
when used for hunting
in the direction of a building livestock
or pets we'll hear more about pets in a
bit
that are within eyesight of the person
discharging the firearm
whoever is found guilty of a first
offense under this paragraph shall have
their hunting license suspended for the
remainder of the year in which the
offense occurred
and the following year
that's pretty reasonable
whoever's found guilty of a second
offense under this paragraph shall lose
their hunting privileges in new
hampshire
for life
all right do it once shame on you do it
twice shame on me
so
is this perfect as drafted
no so
you're going to hear testimony from
representatives of the akc
and they said well you know when we read
this and close our eyes what we see is
somebody rabbit hunting with with dogs
and you could argue that those hunting
dogs are pets
and they are
typically somewhere betwixt the firearm
and
the target
and so
we had a discussion
we're going to try to find an amendment
that'll
define pet a little bit better so that
we don't accidentally ban
hunting for
pheasant rabbit bear whatever it is you
want to with dogs or whatever other
animal you might want to use to do that
that type of thing with
so
that's that's something we're going to
work on
in the future
but that's the impetus for the bill
and
that's why i'm here today that's why i
support this bill
and i
i hope the committee will support this
bill
we certainly do expect to bring an
amendment in the near distant future to
make this bill a little bit better and
i'd love to work with the committee on
that
at this point i'll take any questions
the committee might have
representative green
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
if i let my dog out in the backyard
and i was looking through the glass door
and i see a coyote coming out of the
woods at it
would i have the right to shoot that
coyote
so thank you representative for the
question it's a great question
and so
my answer is yes
and that's why we need an amendment i
think we need an amendment to clean up
um who's whose pet we're referring to
in this in this bill so i think what we
need to do is clean it up to say uh in
the direction of another person's pet
for which the
the shooter doesn't have permission to
be using that pet for the purposes of
hunting um so that it's clear that we're
not referring to the shooter's pet
so i agree that we need an amendment to
make that part better in fact you know
if
i want to put ideas in people's heads
because i love my bill if we dropped pet
from this bill
i think it would be sufficient to meet
the desire of my constituent and i
certainly could
could go down that path to simply scrub
pet from the bill if that's if that's
the quickest cleanest way to to get it
done
thank you
thank you for your testimony witness is
excused thank you
the committee now calls joe hannon gynos
of new hampshire
uh good morning again thank you for
having us here today and thank you for
listening uh joe hannan the vice
president for gunners of new hampshire
uh we're in opposition to this bill not
that
we don't think it's a good idea we don't
think it's a good idea to shoot in the
direction of any of these things but
it's already uh it's against the law to
shoot someone's pet to shoot someone's
livestock uh to shoot at their home
these are all things that are already
illegal if you actually shoot and hit
these things you can be criminally
liable and also civilly liable if you do
any damage to someone's personal
property or
um
pets and livestock
there's also some just like we heard
from the sponsor there are some things
that need to be changed like hunting
retrievers would be one example you know
retrievers are often in front of you but
not you're not pointing at them or
aiming at them you're aiming in the sky
but the retriever is often in front of
you or near you or within eyesight of
you
um
that would be a very big problem
also it says
discharge a firearm when used for
hunting purposes in the direction of
and then it goes on to say within
eyesight of the person discharging the
firearm well direction and eyesight are
not necessarily the same thing and how
do we define that
i am
looking at the chair who is in
directly in front of me that's the
direction but all of you are in eyesight
and i can actually see
the other microphone from here in my in
my eyesight even with the glasses i've
got pretty decent peripheral vision so i
can't shoot anything from that way all
the way over as far as i can see so if i
see a cow
over there
three miles away i would not be allowed
to hunt the deer who was right in front
of me not not you but uh you know that
would be a problem so i don't think the
language is very clear
um and also the i said the person
discharging the firearm you're gonna
have to get the the person uh filing the
charge the officer will have to go out
and actually have to
sit in the exact same spot now this is
not a big problem but what if the vision
what do you do about vision differences
some people may have better vision
others so someone who has poor vision
and can't see 300 yards very clearly and
they're shooting something 50 feet in
front of them
are we going to hold that person to a
different standard because it's their
vision that we're talking about their
their eyesight
so i think there are several problems
with this bill
and i ask you to please it all this bill
thank you
thank you for your testimony the witness
is excused
we now call colonel kevin jordan new
hampshire fishing game
good morning mr chair and honorable
members of the criminal justice
committee thank you for allowing me to
testify today the commission and the
department reviewed this law very
carefully because we certainly are the
ones that as you've already heard
are the ones that are held responsible
for enforcing this type of thing we have
a lot of issues with this
as it's written i think it creates a
number of problems that i want to come
today and make you aware the first one i
will tell you is that we aggressively
very aggressively enforce the 300 foot
rule it's a safety concern for us we get
a lot of calls on it not a lot of calls
but we get a number of calls and we and
i have mandated that each officer take
that very seriously because i don't want
people afraid i don't want people
fearing hearing a gunshot we live in new
hampshire and in the month of november
you hear a lot of gunshots
um
and we i am very confident when i tell
you that we are very strict on it and we
make a few cases on it and we convict
people of it and we do that because it
was a well-crafted piece of legislation
it's easy to prove you have certain
elements involving distance which takes
out a lot of the questions that you just
heard presented very well
regarding direction of sight and proving
that someone was seeing something that's
very difficult if you can imagine to do
in a courtroom and when that's in a bill
you have that becomes an element you
have to prove it
the other problem with this bill is
there is no legal definition
in our statutes for hunting so hunting
falls undertaking
our definitions under 2071 in
undertaking describe the act of hunting
and the problem with that is they
include a lot of other things under that
same definition some of the things are
included in that shooting
killing capturing trapping snaring
pursuing worrying harassing wounding so
all of those actions would fall under
that definition it would prevent
representative green
uh what you just asked would be illegal
under this statute
the other thing that's concerning to me
is property rights people's property
rights so right now i have farmers
that we work with on a regular basis and
i think i don't want to steal the
thunder i think you're going to hear
some of this today but a farmer has the
right or any landowner has a right to
protect their property be it their
domestic dog
chickens in a coop
all of those things and we have provided
we the legislature has provided them and
fish and game the right to protect those
animals and i think that's an important
right that landowners should have they
shouldn't have to stand by and watch
their their animals get decimated by a
by a bear which happens on occasion
or a bobcat what happens typically
they'll make a call to us to respond to
that by the time i get there they could
lose a lot of livestock so they are
permitted through law
under under careful conditions to
dispatch that animal and call us and
report
that um act this law would prevent that
they would not be allowed to do that
there's no provision in here for a
landowner to do that
the other technical the other point that
i want to bring out to you i think
people forget about we have a lot of
laws to address the discharge of a
firearm in an unsafe manner they include
prohibitions which is a 300-foot rule
that we use on a regular basis which all
of all hunting offenses in the state of
new hampshire come with a year loss of
license second offense is a three-year
loss of license
by statute
we have negligent discharge of a firearm
which specifically talks about shooting
or placing people in danger or shooting
at people's properties we have reckless
conduct which is used and it becomes a
felony class b felony if a person uses a
deadly weapon and places someone in in
danger of imminent serious bodily injury
we have criminal mischief which is a
class b felony if you discharge a
firearm at an occupied structure
we have unauthorized use of a firearm
which covers the compact zones the areas
of small neighborhoods or close
neighborhoods where it would be unsafe
to shoot so there are a lot of existing
laws now both in criminal code and
and in chapter 18 fish and game statutes
that address this
so i feel that it is adequate adequately
addressed and then finally the other
technical diff dif conflict in this
current change that's proposed
under fishing game and that would be the
loss of license so the loss of license i
think in the proposed bill would be a uh
the rest of the year
which happens anyway the following year
which would be automatic under statute
and then a second offense would be loss
of your license for life where you don't
have any statute no i'm sufficient gain
believe it or not where people lose
their license for life even shooting a
human being
they are entitled after a 10-year
suspension
to reapply after hunter safety and
making some amends to get their license
back so that would conflict with current
statutes that are very specific on how
we lose our license in a length of time
so based on all of those facts
i would ask you to
consider itlling this bill thank you
very much
representative rory
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
if you heard the uh the scenario that
the representative gave
would that have fallen under the
reckless
use of a firearm where where he fired
discharged it towards a barn you would
have to prove uh a couple of things you
would have to prove that it that that
act placed someone or the property in
danger and from what i'm hearing and
again we're
it as you know it's hard to to second
guess when you don't have all the facts
and i can tell you from doing this for
three decades there's three sides to
every story and the truth lies somewhere
there in the middle
but if you could and i am confident if
one of my officers went there and felt
that someone was in danger by that shot
they would have taken steps to address
it we do that regularly so while that is
um
you know that gunshot i'm sure
frightened that farmer i'm sure it
concerned him because this guy is you
know within sight of him but i i am
confident if there was danger a reckless
reckless act that they would have been
charged with so my answer to that would
be i don't think it meant that from what
i heard i don't think it meant the
elements to be proven thank you
representative newman you're recognized
thank you and justin
as a follow-up to your answer there if
if that wayward shot had had hit a pet
or hit
the way things that are described in
this
law would your office have been been
able to then make a charge on that if
you had evidence that in fact
the shot did
hit one of them absolutely absolutely
it's clear there's several uh statutes
that he could choose depending on the
elements matt but yes we would have the
ability to charge for that uh we have
currently i worked on a case this
morning where where an individual's dog
was shot
by an angry hunter
and he was charged with with a felony
and facing charges for that
representative newman you're recognized
for a follow-up listen could you could
you just clear up for me as a matter of
fact i live in a city
but i do know about the 300 foot
yes law and as i recall off the top of
my head
there is some limitation on that you had
to have a certain number of houses or
something within a proximity is there a
limitation on that so so there's two
laws represented that would cover that
so we have a law to which is prohibition
[Music]
2073 i believe it is
that
does it 3a which which says
you cannot discharge a firearm or a bow
any kind of a firearm or a bow within
300 feet of a permanently occupied
dwelling
unless you have permission from the land
owner that you're shooting from
the other law that would address that is
the compact area so that that was born
because of some issues we had with duck
hunters on the coast
where you have smaller neighborhoods and
we define what we the legislature
defined a compact zone and a compact
zone is six or more continuous homes or
occupier dwellings within 300 feet of
each other and a 300 foot rule around
that so it basically eliminated the
hunting in a in a
condensed neighborhood
also one of my concerns about this bill
is this bill would eliminate hunting in
a good portion of the state of new
hampshire
because there's places you can see homes
a half a mile away and if this bill were
to pass even though that round would
would be very unlikely to reach there it
would end the ability to hunt in that
area so that's very concerning to us
thank you very much for the information
thank you very much
representative burt
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
your testimony sir
i know a lot of people in goffstown use
the rail trail i have chickens so what
you're saying is in we see houses
everywhere sure
and we do have koi dogs
other animals that attack small
chickens and small dogs you know i hear
about it every now and then or even they
take cats so if we saw that with this
bill passed we wouldn't be able to
protect that animal by shooting the
bad animal
to protect the uh that's correct the way
i'm reading that i don't believe you
would be able to do that all right thank
you
thank you very much
thank you for your testimony the
witnesses is excused
the committee now calls courtney
nicholson
sportsmen's alliance
good morning everyone i'm here on behalf
of the sportsman's alliance um we have a
memo that was submitted by our
consultants at sportsman's alliance that
i'll be reading aloud um don't mind me
i'm a little nervous this is the first
time i've
spoke in front of this many people
dear members of the house criminal
justice and public safety committee on
behalf of hunters in new hampshire and
sportsmen and women across the country
the sportsman's alliance asked you to
oppose house bill 1310
which could end untold hunting
opportunities across new hampshire
house bill 1310 would prohibit hunters
from discharging a firearm in the
direction of any buildings livestock or
pets within their eyesight no matter how
far away
the bill is worded ambiguously and could
be utilized to stop virtually any
hunting
depending on the terrain and the weather
condition a person can see buildings or
livestock in fields at distances of far
more than a mile and certainly far
beyond the range of hunting rifles
this bill doesn't make any delineation
between a rifle and a shotgun which has
an even shorter range
further the bill prohibits shooting in
the direction of a visible pet and makes
no exception for a hunting dog
both bird and rabbit hunters commonly
and safely shoot in the same direction
as pursuing as a pursuing hunting dog
that has successfully flushed game
there are also genuine questions about
the necessity for this type of
legislation
hunting is remarkably safe
for example a person is 11 times more
likely to be injured while playing
volleyball
19 times more likely to be injured while
snowboarding i have
25 times more likely to be injured
cheerleading or bicycle riding
35 times more likely to be injured
playing soccer or skateboarding also
done that
105 more times likely to be injured
playing tackle football
hunters take safely extremely seriously
and have spearheaded laws that maintain
hunter education apprentice hunting and
blaze orange requirements
this shared commitment is what has made
hunting one of the safest recreational
activities in the country including new
hampshire
hb 1310 would severely restrict hunting
opportunities without justification
hunter safety works best through
continued education
for these reasons the sportsman's
alliance asked the members of the house
criminal justice and public safety
committee to oppose this legislation
i wanted to further speak
as a hunter myself
this is a letter of course i'm up here
reading from the sportsman's alliance
i'm actually personally a
massachusetts resident don't hold that
against me
i grew up coming to new hampshire every
single year as a child and now that i'm
a hunter i come up here as well to enjoy
new hampshire and hopefully at some
point in the near future i will be
making the obvious upgrade to becoming a
new hampshire resident um
i've upland game hunted in a bunch of
different states that i've lived in um
mostly out in kansas and nebraska for
pheasants and in michigan for rough
grouse
this past fall i had my opportunity to
harvest my first rough grouse
over our hunting dog lindsay she's an
english setter
and it has become an absolute wonderful
tradition in our family
and we just got a new little setter just
before christmas named piper
now as
um
you all mostly know and how we read in
our letter
this bill wouldn't take into any account
for hunting over these hunting
dogs it's my little picture of our
family
as you know this is a very important
part of our heritage as hunters
it's pretty much all we do in our family
to spend time together to spend time
with our dogs who are not only pets
they're part of the family and they're
hunting dogs
and so personally just from myself as
well
i urge you to oppose this bill thank you
very much
thank you for your testimony
the witness is excused
the committee now calls stacy ober
american kennel club
good morning chairman abbas and members
of the committee my name is stacey ober
i am the legislative liaison for the
american kennel club here in new england
and i want to just acknowledge that we
have serious concerns about house bill
1310 is written
you've heard some of those concerns
expressed already so i'll just
acknowledge that
the american kennel club is a
135 year old not not-for-profit
organization we represent 5 000 dog
clubs across the country
including 14 here in new hampshire
our concern with the bill is that it
does not distinguish between
hunting dogs and
who also are our companion animals the
akc
encourages and strongly supports the
interaction and mutual enjoyment of
sporting activities
by owners with their dogs
and in 2019 for instance
we sanctioned 141 events in new
hampshire in which more than 24
300 dogs participated
so we're very concerned about
uh the
language in the bill as filed perhaps
having a chilling effect on those who
engage and enjoy in those types of
canine sporting activities that include
hunting field trials
agility
and other performance events
so thank you for your consideration
in opposing the bill as file thank you
thank you for your testimony the witness
is excused
the committee now calls robert johnson
new hampshire farm
bureau thank you mr chair and members of
the committee for the record my name is
rob johnson and i'm here representing
the new hampshire farm bureau as a
federation's policy director farm bureau
is a federation of new hampshire's ten
county farm bureau organizations
consisting of close to 2 000 family
memberships and another 1 000 other
types of members supporting and such and
we are in in opposition to the bill is
drafted you've heard in different ways
many of our concerns in particular there
are no provisions in the bill for
landowners
on their own property as a particular
concern as was alluded to earlier as
well again as it's been alluded to
earlier
hunting is not defined in statute and
we're concerned what does this mean for
any landowner protecting their their own
livestock or animals
we also have concerns with the phrasing
within eyesight
as you've heard earlier it means
different things to different people
and
in our discussions with fishing game and
appears and statue
currently covers what's needed to be
covered so with that i'll leave it and
thank you for time and attention
thank you for your testimony the witness
is excused
the committee now calls david thoreau
david leroux um
i'm actually
not a hunter with the state just because
i don't have enough time because of all
the things i have to do but i am a
landowner and uh i'm currently building
a farm i own 83 acres
so there's obviously problems with
provisions on defining hunting
the direction seems very vague to me
that's very different than act
we had talk about the different statutes
that already cover actual uh breaking of
the actual laws about actually causing
harm intent all those things that i'm
not the expert at but he spoke well on
um
the
beyond the subjectiveness of this
i would agree that losing your hunting
license for life um because i plan to
get my hunting license and somebody who
is an avid hunter many people that i
know from the north country they use
hunting as a primary means of um
getting their food
i actually know many people who that's
one of their primary ways of getting
their meat and if you haven't bought
groceries in a while i can tell you what
meat costs so somebody who has time and
wants to get meat should be allowed that
um with the subjective and somewhat
vague
criteria in this
then it would be very open to the
possibility that somebody who did not
have ill intent and somebody who did not
actually violate any of the other
current existing rules could possibly um
and or if their hunting area typically
involves buildings that are within
eyesight again very broad i can see
houses from over a mile away from where
i live
that they could possibly lose their
license for life i think that's way over
the top
also there's the question that if we
have somebody who is a landowner or a
farmer who has animals that could be at
risk it's up to their responsibility
whether or not they want to post their
land to prevent hunting on their land
you can also as i understand it post
land and still maintain current use uh
standards of tax breaks within uh
criteria because there's recreational
use you can disallow hunting on your
property and still have
landowner permission landowners can
shoot and do what they need to in
defense of their animals um the problems
are many with this and as a landowner
who is building a barn to eventually
have cows in we already have chickens
and as a landowner who has had over a
dozen chickens killed in about five
minutes from a black bear at my previous
residence in campton i can tell you this
bill needs to go thank you
thank you for your testimony
the committee now calls penny dean
good morning thank you again for hearing
my testimony i'm still from concord and
i want to make it clear i'm not being
paid as a lobbyist
no one's paying me to be here i'm
strictly on behalf of myself it actually
cost me money i lose income to be here
so i can tell you that i certainly have
strong feelings this bill needs to be
itl for several reasons first of all
if the introducing speaker is correct
and i make no opinion nor disperse them
in any way
the particular troopers and fish and
game officers really need to be sent
back to the police academy because they
missed their classes that day
because if it was as said
631 one three would take care of it
there are plenty of statutes that would
allow for criminal charges for the
situation as mentioned
they're in place
tons of them i could spend hours lifting
them off you it's not a good time bit of
your time to listen
but more importantly
vague terms invite abuse
and there are more vague terms in this
bill than carter has pills
and when i think about defending or
proving
or disproving as a practical matter
a case
when we have things like pets
i didn't notice your pet i thought it
was a wild dog
you know wild cat wild whatever
um eyesight again whose eyesight are we
talking about with or without glasses
and so i just see this bill as being not
needed
if the statute of limitations hasn't
passed
they should go check again with the
person who was shot near and see if
there can be a remedy done or was this
person just overly sensitive to a
shotgun that went off 100 yards away you
know we don't know but everything
should not
be taken and said we're going to pass a
new law when what i see happening here
is just abuses being heaped on and quite
frankly
leading to a lot of troubles both for
law enforcement and citizens because i
pity the poor law enforcement officer or
fish and game officer that would try to
enforce or even interpret the statute
and
so therefore i'm happy to answer any
questions but i go back to 630 131 place
another in danger of serious bodily
injury
like i said there's a plethora of
statutes and if in fact
those that responded didn't know maybe
they do need remedial education i don't
know
but i'm happy to answer any questions
about it
or about practical application of this i
just think there is none
and ask that you itl please
thank you for your testimony the witness
is excused
at this time we will now close the
public hearing on house bill 1310.
at this time we will now open the
executive session on house bill 1310.
representative burt you wish to be
recognized
yes mr chairman and thank you for
recognizing me
i would like to make a motion for house
bill 1310 of
itl some motion of inexpensive legislate
is there second seconded by
representative wallace
representative burke do you wish to
speak to the motion
yes mr chairman and thank you
we've heard all the testimony
um
i guess the you know other than the
testimony which was great uh to be
opposed to this bill
there's three key things that really
stuck to me from the prime sponsor was
the farmer did not see the shot
he didn't see the gentleman shooting the
gun
so he really doesn't know where it was
shooting i mean he knows where the
turkey was and where the barn was and
where the
beef cow were
and from what i also understood is that
everybody agreed that
the shot was a safe shot
it might have been disturbing to the
individual and i'm sorry for that but it
was a safe shot because it was
determined
everybody agreed that the beef cows in
the barn were not going to be hit by
this shot
and they also said that this bill is not
perfectly drafted and that is very true
i've looked at this bill to see if we
could fix it and there's really no
fixing it because current laws
protect all the scenarios of a
misplaced shocked
you know which is very rare from what i
understand in new hampshire
so for that reasons
and all the great testimony we just
heard
i will be supporting the itl of 1310
thank you
at this time the matter will now be put
to question if you were in support of
the motion of inexpedient to legislate
please say yes if you are opposed please
say nay
the clerk will not call the roll
vice chairman roy
yes
representative welch
yes representative burt
yes
representative rhodes
representative greene yes clerk votes
yes representative testerman yes
representative true yay
representative pratt
yes
representative marston
representative harriet gathright
representative pantalakis yes
representative o'hearn
representative bordenay
yes
representative muse
representative newman
yes
representative baldwin
representative conley
yes
representative klein knight yes
representative bradley yes
chairman addis
the chair votes yes
20 eas zero nays one not voting
so moved no objections
representative burt will be preparing a
majority report yes it would and i would
hope it would go on the consent calendar
it's already been it's already been
moved for consent
thank you mr chairman
at this time we'll now close the
executive session on house bill 1310.
the committee will be in recess until 11
30.
so
um
is that
is one subcommittee
i couldn't i don't think so
i was gonna flinch if i heard my names i
didn't understand what the question was
i'm going to see
what is it a motorcycle bill
no what is it
i
couldn't hear what he was saying
the acoustics in here are really oh
i can't
strain
my
can you
where did you get this paper
dennis
why did you have this
maybe i hope the acoustics aren't this
bad when we're in sessions
i mean maybe it's because if it fills up
with people
it helps with the acoustics it's how
you know i've got so much room here
yeah
i i've had
people from airbnb say would you like to
rent something yeah i do
these tables
listen
i know
i don't know it's actually from boston
so
when they get back in committee i
believe that i'm sitting here so
everyone i
that's right
you say
i mean in committee you've got some room
for like
some notes
let's explain let's play it on scott he
probably knows
yes
i do not know
battery
but he appointed people what bill
when you come back maybe you can help by
microphone back in
[Music]
i'll just speak louder
who knows
i i don't know which i
i didn't know we had any
study i guess we did have some interim
studies
last week
so it was exactly
okay
yes
can you hear me
the acoustics are good
is
the chiefs are opposed
questions
yes
yes ma'am can i help you yeah did you
write down
40 that i um know
outside of myself it was roy o'hearn
myself and walters
yeah
so bad i couldn't even pick up the
numbers
oh
you
at this time we will now open the public
hearing on house bill 1178
prohibiting the state from enforcing any
federal
statute regulation or presidential
executive order that restricts or
regulates the right of the people to
keep and bear arms at this time the
committee recognizes representative
burt to introduce the bill
thank you mr chairman and fine committee
members
mr chairman
house bill 1178
is a
easy clean
common sense bill
very common sense
it prohibits
the state from enforcing any federal
statute as you said regulation
presidential executive order that
restricts or regulates the right of the
people in new hampshire
to keep and bear arms
i always feel that local police should
enforce
local
laws here in new hampshire
the state police and local police should
not be doing the federal
government's job because then we have to
pay for it
the federal government has more money
than they can handle
and if they don't have enough money
they just print more
so they have
the money to enforce any laws that they
wish to enforce
and that's all this bill does it's very
common sense
so i hope everybody will vote for it
because
if the federal government wants to come
into new hampshire and enforce any of
their laws
let them
but they're not going to have the help
of our local and state police thank you
mr speaker
chairman you're sitting in the speaker's
chair
so thank you mr chair i'm standing yes
you are excused representative thank you
the committee now calls representative
bob lynn
thank you mr chairman i'm going to make
my remarks very very brief um as as i
think probably all the committee knows
this is kind of a
this we went through this exercise
before
last year
i support
i support this bill
but i think that it needs to have
a section two
which which sort of defines the
limitations of the bill
because if you just if you just pass
this bill
and you don't do anything else
there will be an argument what happens
in the
you know very frequent circumstance
where there is
a violation
of
the police are investigating or federal
agents and the local police are
investigating
a number of violations committed by or
allegedly committed by somebody
some of which may be only a violation of
federal law where there's no
counterpart state law some of which may
be a violation of only state law where
there's no counterpart federal law and
some of which may be
of a
conduct that could arguably violate both
laws like for example
drug offenses
if you don't put in
a section that was in the bill
last year that's that basically says
what happens in those circumstances
you can you you
the bill is interpret is open to to both
interpretations
somebody could say some local official
could say well
you know we've been asked to participate
with the federal government in a in an
investigation
part of which
involves a violation only of federal gun
laws that where there's no equivalent
state law
we read this bill we read this bill if
it becomes law to say we can't do that
we cannot
participate some other local official
might say well yes
it you know but there are other
violations here so we can participate
because there are other violations of
law and there's no prohibition on that
it seems to me that that's the kind of
uncertainty
that you don't want to have
i know there was a language and i'm i i
actually still have the language i'm
happy to submit it to the committee um
uh
that from from uh last year
uh talking about
the the fact that
this the intent of this bill and i think
i assume that that is the intent but if
i'm you know if if
if i'm wrong i suppose somebody will
tell me but i assume it's the intent not
to prohibit
the local authorities from participating
in investigations where it's
it's something other than solely a
violation of a federal gun law that
doesn't have any state
counterpart because
if if the intent
were to were to make it broader than
that
i mean you that's
it seems to me that is would be a real
problem because there are all kinds of
investigations going on
in this state and other states where
there are multiple
violations of law where state and where
you want to encourage the state and the
federal government to cooperate with
each other i mean and that's why i think
you need
uh some language in there that that uh
that makes it clear that that kind of
cooperation is not prohibited the other
the other point the other two points
i'll make very quickly is that and it's
probably
uh it should be obvious
this
this bill as as drafted if it passes it
has no teeth
there are no provisions in this bill
that say what happens
let's assume
that some that there is a case in which
the only thing that is
that the federal government is
investigating is a violation of federal
gun laws where there's no equivalent
state violation and so
this law if it were enacted would say
the states can't cooperate
suppose they do
suppose a police chief
decides that he wants to cooperate
and he does
what's the remedy this bill doesn't say
any evidence that's ex that's gathered
as a result of that investigation can't
be used in state court it doesn't say
that the police chief who authorizes the
cooperation can be disciplined or a
police officer who does that can be
disciplined
so
you know it's it's
i think the reality is that this is kind
of a
if you pay if we pass this law and
there's nothing else in it you've kind
of made a public statement you've sort
of declared you know this is what the
legislature thinks but you haven't given
it any teeth because there's no
enforcement mechanism
you might want to think about whether
there should be some enforcement
mechanism if we really mean what we say
maybe there should be some provision
that creates an exclusionary rule
if if there's a violation or allows the
you know whoever violates it some state
official to be in some way disciplined
that's that's something i think you may
want to think about but
that's about really that's about all i
have i'm happy to answer questions if
anybody hasn't
representative newman you were
recognized
thank you mr chair
i have some confusion about the law and
what you just testified to and maybe you
could help me clear that up by
a law that i that i think about where i
i don't have the legal expertise to even
know if i'm saying this right
where we talk about guns in a school
and that there is a federal law that
applies in those cases
but there is no for people of 18 i
believe
and there is no equivalent state law
for those
cases but in talking to police and
chiefs and whatever
somehow they are able through public
safety lawyers or somewhere to be able
to
get somebody to remove themselves from
the school or they have to come up with
some other way to get someone that is
carrying an arm in a school
so am i just totally confused it can't
be
you can't figure it out what's your
opinion of
how this law relates to that kind of
conflict that i
see well yeah i i mean i guess
i think as a general matter in other
words if you're if you're saying for
example
if there was a if the
if the federal government were
investigating an alleged violation of
the gun free the federal country school
zones act
which we don't have the equivalent of
could this you know if this were passed
could the state cooperate in that
i think it would really depend on the
facts of the case because for example it
might
you know
it might often be the case that there
would be some basis for the state to be
concerned about you know is there is
there some threat of a violation of
state laws an assault shooting whatever
that would that would you know authorize
the state to be
to render assistance
i think that's close to what i was
trying to say it's you do have a federal
gun free school zone
if someone
and we don't have an equivalent state
law
right now the way the situation is now
without without this law
and someone shows up at the school armed
with the ar-15 and they call the police
and the police just want to get the
person to leave
is there any state law that they can
rely on for them to do that or do you
actually have to wait for atf to come or
can they talk the guy off the property
or what's the situation in that
hypothetical situation
i guess i i would assume if someone
showed up at at a school with an ar-15
and they were you know
i mean
i guess you have to talk about the
you have to talk about the situation i
mean
you know there as as i understand the
federal gun free school zones act there
are very there are various
exceptions to the
you know to when it applies and i mean
i'll just give you an example
i'm a target shooter i often have a a
rifle in the in the back of my car and
when my kids were younger and were going
to school i often dropped them off at
school with a gun in the back it was
obviously it was in a case it was locked
it was unloaded you know i wasn't
planning to to take it out but i so i
guess if
you know
if that was the situation there would be
no basis to believe that there was a
violation of state law or federal law
but if somebody you know
we're we're walking into the we're
we're walking into a high school with a
loaded ar-15 or any other gun for that
matter i think the police might have
would certainly have a basis to to at
least find out what was going on
and said to you know and so to that
extent to cooperate if you will
thank you
representative true
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
were you looking back in your notes to a
previous bill
yes it was i believe it was
sb senate bill 154 from last year in
fact i remember i believe i had some
discussion with representative
uh
representative burt about this
uh because he had some concern about the
section two at the time
um and and we we sort of had some back
and forth i sent him a proposal about
you know
trying to address some of his concerns i
i
i didn't really talk to him after that
so i assume it didn't address his
concerns but
um
i was trying to address
some of his concerns
thank you
thank you very much mr chair thank you
representative
the committee now calls sean lock new
hampshire department of justice
good morning chair abbas and members of
the criminal justice and public safety
committee my name is sean locke i am an
assistant attorney general and i am
testifying today on behalf of the
department of justice
the department does not take a position
on the policy behind this legislation
but is here today to raise concerns many
of which illustrated by representative
lin
that is currently drafted the bill could
negatively impact law enforcement
activities and pose legal challenges in
the state
as introduced the bill prohibits state
and local resources to enforce
administer or cooperate with
federal gun laws and regulations that
are inconsistent or unaddressed by state
law
focusing on the word cooperate
this runs a great risk of hindering
criminal investigations for a few
reasons
first other statutes authorize state
police to share information with the
federal government to prevent and detect
crime
this is a critical partnership and keeps
the state safe
but the language as drafted would place
a cloud on this relationship because the
challenges it challenges whether state
police
could share this data
as it could be used by the federal
government to enforce federal gun law
the second example here would be
state and local law enforcement
routinely cooperate with the dea
fbi and other federal agencies to
conduct drug interdiction operations and
combat drug trafficking
many drug-related arrests involve the
seizure and forfeiture of illegal
firearms under federal law
or the arrest of those disqualified to
possess a firearm under federal law
as drafted the bill calls into doubt the
ability of state of the state to
participate in such joint adventure or
joint endeavors
additionally
two other kind of sets of concerns here
as introduced the bill may harm the
state's ability to receive grant funding
from the federal government
current grants with the u.s department
of justice require law enforcement to
submit information to the national
instant criminal background check system
pertaining to convictions that are
federal disqualifiers for purchasing
firearms
as drafted the bill would limit the
state and local government's abilities
to qualify for key federal funding or
could limit those abilities
last the bill has drafted raises
constitutional questions such as whether
the legislature
can dictate how the executive branch
investigates criminal offenses and there
also may be preemption issues of federal
law
the department of justice is willing to
work with a work committee uh to address
some of these concerns and see if we can
craft a bill see if a bill can come out
of that effort to that would satisfy all
the parties involved or all the
interests but
for now i'm happy to take questions from
the committee
representative roy you should be
recognized for a question
if the chairman may inquire with the
question can you explain what the
concern is about preemption
simply that they're with the
kind of
existence of federal law
it would be supreme they can't the
federal government can't order state
actors to engage in kind of federal law
enforcement efforts but there may be
questions of whether or not in engaging
in a particular activity
in one of these joint endeavors
can we kind of tell the federal
government no you can't enforce the law
in this circumstance because we're
working together we are limited in only
enforcing state law in these
circumstances that would be i think the
kind of main example of preemption it's
not as significant a concern
but it was one that we flagged as a
possible issue that could arise
representative roy
yes thank you thank you for taking my
question
is it not the case that
occasionally during joint investigations
that sometimes state law enforcement
officials are sworn in as temporary
agents of the federal government
that does happen in certain
circumstances yes thank you
representative testament
thank you thank you for taking my
question
you mentioned
monies that you received from
grants you received from the federal
government
what percentage of your overall budget
is that
kind of grand money makeup
i don't have those exact numbers
available to me but that's something we
could i could have our administrator
look into and
provide additional detail but i don't
know that on the top of my head i'm
sorry
conley
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking the question what would be the
effect
on law enforcement in the state if
federal grants that we currently receive
would be uh
eliminated or rescinded if this were to
pass again
you know similar to representative
testerman's question i can't speak to
every law enforcement agency and how
much federal funding funding they
receive but you know the concern is
definitely a significant one on our part
because we also sub grant funding to
state our local law enforcement agencies
as well in terms of the funds that we
receive to assist in whether it's drug
interdiction efforts or other efforts
that the department undertakes with the
assistance of local agencies
representative conley thank you so if
i'm hearing you right this would hinder
law enforcement in our state if this
were to pass in the grant funding where
we're sending
it creates that potential because again
there's that question about what does
cooperate mean in these circumstances
representative true
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
i know you've expressed uh hesitancy
about just saying we can't cooperate
with the federal government
but isn't this
pretty particular that we can't
it's only talking about like second
amendment issues firearms
is not talking about
drug enforcement or
correct
the concern arises though that in this
context of that cooperation federal
government may be enforced as well and
so kind of the example being that often
times in these drug investigations there
are firearms involved and so
if the person arrested has not committed
a violation of state law but only
federal law in possessing those firearms
is that cooperation with the federal
government to enforce federal government
that's the that's the cloud that exists
here in the concern that really
underlies a lot of uh the department's
testimony today thank you
if the chairman inquired with the
question can you
provide any any instances where other
states passed a similar policy where
they were denied any funding or grant
grant money through the federal
government
that is something we have to look into i
don't have that answer kind of readily
available i'm not aware of
kind of the impact other states have
faced in these circumstances
if they and even if states have passed
similar laws
thank you for taking my question
the witness is excused thank you
the committee calls alan rice gun owners
of america
good morning mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is alan
rice i'm a resident of bedford new
hampshire
and i'm here representing gun owners of
america
in support of house bill 1178
i wanted to address
some of what representative lynn
spoke about
he said that
there's no teeth to it it's our
expectation
new hampshire law enforcement has a
reputation of high integrity more so
than other states
um should this be enacted into law it's
our expectation that they would follow
the law
i don't think we need draconian
penalties to force new hampshire law
enforcement to follow the law because
that's generally what they do
it's a very simple concept in house bill
1178 state and local police are hired
trained and compensated with state and
local tax dollars
federal agents are hired trained and
compensated with federal tax dollars
we shouldn't be employing
state and local police to enforce
federal laws
we have federal agents for that
um
one of the issues that comes to mind
quite often
with there's a lot of federal government
overreach is in the regulation of gun
dealers
do we really want
state and local police going into gun
dealers to do records checks inspections
verify that the inventory in the dealer
records is actually physically in the
building
that's a job for the batf that's not a
job for state and local law enforcement
when a firearm is stolen from a dealer
there are federal penalties
but it's burglary or theft depending on
the nature of the crime there's also
state penalties so there'd be state laws
enforced
should the federal government you know
decide they want to aggressively enforce
the federal gun free school zones act
and that was mentioned earlier but there
are exemptions and the most common
exemption is if the person carrying the
firearm has a perimeter license issued
by the state in which the school is
located in they can carry a gun new
hampshire does not prohibit adults key
word is adults
from carrying a gun in a school and i
believe if my memory serves me it was
attorney general joe foster or former
attorney general joe foster who had
issued opinions saying hey
state and local police can't enforce
this it's not a state law
and his opinions are more consistent
with you know supreme court cases
um the one on point is
prince versus united states from back in
the 90s when
the court ruled the federal government
can't compel states to do their work
that was a firearms case
i mentioned some other cases in my
letter that are not firearms but in
similar vein
the federal government cannot compel the
states to do their work well if they
can't compel the states to do their work
the state shouldn't voluntarily do their
work
new hampshire likes to say we're a
fiscally conservative state
this is part of being fiscally
conservative it's not doing someone
else's job for them so based on all of
that and the information i supplied you
in my letter which i did email the
committee last night i would ask that
you vote house bill 1178 ought to pass
without any amendments or changes and i
will be happy to take any questions
thank you and thank you for taking the
question this believe it or not is in
good faith can you did i hear you say
that
current
uh
pr legal you know the current situation
in new hampshire is that state
officers do not enforce federal law um
is there any situation
currently
where that would overlap uh or is it
just that's the standard that's the norm
it wouldn't happen i'm referring to a
letter
that former attorney general joe foster
issued i don't remember what year it was
but he's been out of office now for like
five years so it was back a ways
and his specific letter was
with regard to the federal gun free
school zones act
and that that is a federal law
and if an adult i want to emphasize
adult so someone like you or i is
observed carrying a firearm in school
that's not a state crime and even though
there's a federal law with specific
exemptions state and local police should
not be enforcing federal laws
representative connolly you're
recognizing where i'm going with that is
if that's the norm is this law needed
because if that's already the standard
in our state would it not would that
practice and standard not continue
well representative i appreciate that
question um it's always good to codify
things in law that attorney generals say
former attorney general foster's been
out of office now for quite a while some
other attorney general could come in and
read our constitution in our laws and
issue a completely different opinion but
if the legislature codifies it in
statute well then it's black and white
it's in statute
representative newman
thank you for
taking my question can you speak up
please sir
thank you for taking my question
um
do you see any contradiction in this law
which is one that we're trying to pass
that would say
that
local police cannot and should not
enforce federal law
and another one we heard previously that
said that state police and local police
cannot and should not do anything to
discourage
local police from enforcing laws like
immigration laws so i see a conflict
between the
position between in those two bills
represent comment about that
representative newman was there a
question there
yes my question was does the witness see
any contradiction in the fact in
enforcing of gun law and not enforcing
an immigration law we have two bills in
front of the house to do that right now
well
i didn't hear the testimony on the other
bill i stepped out in hallway to return
some emails because it wasn't a firearms
bill
gun owners of america is a second
amendment advocacy organization we are
singularly focused on second amendment
rights
having said that my personal opinion as
a resident of new hampshire as a
taxpayer in the state of new hampshire
is that state and local law enforcement
should be enforcing state and local laws
and federal law enforcement should be
enforcing federal laws
thank you for your testimony and i
didn't mean to put you on his butt thank
you not at all thank you thank you very
much
thank you for your testimony the witness
is excused
committee now calls john marasco new
hampshire state police
good morning everyone uh thank you for
your service my name is john marasco i'm
a major with new hampshire state police
and i oversee two out of the three
bureaus one of which is the
investigative services bureau
the other is the justice information
bureau which encompasses the gun line
the investigative services bureau is
responsible for the major crime unit the
narcotics investigations unit the
special investigations unit and the
information and analysis center
i just uh listening to a.g locke's
testimony i just wanted to compliment
that
you know certainly the number of crimes
that are committed across state lines we
work very closely with our federal
partners in fact we have task force
officers that are assigned to the dea to
the fbi to the u.s postal inspection
service and
those responsibilities are really
focused on drug crime for the most part
and
it's common obviously as you all know
when you have a drug offense there
oftentimes is a weapon involved so atf
is involved in a lot of these cases
sometimes
the federal agency might be the lead on
a drug investigation that takes place
here in new hampshire and state and
local police support them in the drug
investigation but as that investigation
continues
you may seize a firearm and there is
going to be potentially federal firearms
charges
that are brought forth in some cases
they might be brought forth at the state
level depending on the crime so
that collaboration and that partnership
that we have with our our federal uh
agencies is vital to um to what we do
here and as far as grants go
certainly those grants
hundreds of thousands of dollars
sometimes into the millions of dollars
focused on um you know the opioid
situation and drug crimes across the
board and and part of that
grant application is going to be focused
on collaboration and partnership
so that's that is very real the only
other thing i did want to say is on the
active shooter scenario
escape safe school zones that aside if
there's an active shooter taking place
anywhere in the state i can tell you
from the state police standpoint when we
arrive there we're going to go in and
identify and mitigate that threat as
quickly as possible to save lives so we
would deal with the uh the federal
limitations after the fact but if
children are being injured or killed
we're going in there
happy to take any questions
representative newman
thank you for taking my question and
it's similar to the one i asked just
previously would the state police
find difficulty if they had several
lawyers some that said cooperate with
some federal laws and others that said
don't cooperate with others how would
that affect the state police
so i heard your question originally sir
we do have a
fair and impartial policing policy that
was put in place
at least two if not three years ago now
and that policy delineates those
responsibilities of ice versus the new
hampshire state police or law
enforcement agencies many have adopted
that policy
so there are some parameters that were
set forth there based on uh on federal
law and um
state considerations as well as far as
what we're talking about here
with regards to you know gun and guns
and crimes
there is that overlap with uh you know
with what we deal with in the drug world
in particular not to say major crime
isn't another issue
certainly when we have a homicide case
many times our federal authorities will
come in and assist us with that if a gun
was used to try to track the gun down in
other cases they may call us and ask us
for their our assistance in in some
capacity but
there is a policy on that one this one
here
guns happen to be involved in drug
crimes frequently and so we work
together on those there is no policy on
that
thank you thank you
representative roy
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
a
specific scenario
the president united states
issues an executive order that says
assault weapons are hereby banned
this bill
would be designed to stop that how would
that impact
or or would you be able to work within
the parameters of such a bill
so assault weapons are banned meaning so
we're talking more are we talking about
the sale or we're talking about the
possession
either or by an executive order that was
not in comporting with new hampshire
existing law
i'd have to i'd have to conduct some
research on that i'm not not sure how
that would apply but actually i have to
rely on uh hulk for more insight on that
okay thank you thank you
if the chair may inquire with a question
and thank you in advance for taking my
question
what are the circumstances that would
occur let's say if the dea were to
contact the state police or even
perhaps local law enforcement and
request assistance with
perhaps executing a raid on a medical
cannabis facility which is still illegal
under federal law
is there a policy right now that the new
hampshire state police would
have to adhere to
we do not have a policy on that now
and if i may ask with a follow-up is
there any policy preventing the new
hampshire state police from
participating with the dea in executing
that raid
there is no policy that would prevent us
from doing that
however that's something that certainly
would fall under the federal purview and
at that point really they would they
would be the lead like i said before
there are many cases where the federal
government is the lead on an
investigation
and they might ask us for
tactical support
they might ask us for the perimeter to
make sure that the public is safe and
nobody
goes near the the residents or whatever
dwelling they might be addressing and we
do deal with that all the time
you know where the federal government
has an arrest warrant for an individual
they ask for assistance from state or
local law enforcement uh but i can tell
you you know only from a state police
standpoint that if it's their warrant
they typically will execute the warrant
and we will provide some layer of
support
but generally speaking
it might be after the fact that the
search if there's a search warrant as
well
if they request our tactical team then
certainly there will be conversations
about how we can assist there so we do
the best we can to support our federal
partners but when it comes to a legal
question like that
if it's a federal crime typically it's
going to be a federal warrant and a
federal execution in most cases
but if they again if they need
assistance on the tactical front um or
something to support
their warrant and their execution of the
warrant
then we would always try to be available
to help
thank you for taking my question
the witness is excused
the committee now calls david larue
david larue um
now i don't have the answer to uh
the question of
who
who currently would foot the bill if we
had state police and local police going
along with in support
does that come from my tax dollars in my
town my state tax dollars
i would agree with the premise that if
the feds are going to do something well
they already take however much of my
money that they say they want and i
don't have much to say about it
so why don't we not let my town and my
local residents and my local taxes also
go to that if it's the case and like i
say i don't know this is my question
where um
the towns are reimbursed for whatever
their expenses are if the state is
reimbursed for uh assisting with the
feds then maybe that's uh maybe that's
something but ultimately follow the
money trail
we do talk a lot about state versus
federal and we have lots of examples in
other areas outside of firearms where
there is federal overreach and if it was
a policy that was good policy for new
hampshire i would think we would have it
we spend 365 days a year arguing about
state policy so if we don't have
something on the books for new hampshire
we should probably slow down and examine
why we're assisting the feds in doing
that that said i am a great supporter of
our union and i love being part of the
federal government i think there are
great protections um you know so this is
definitely a sticky situation that
requires a lot of thought
i don't know the ramifications on the
judicial side and the state police side
but i definitely think the premise is
solid and maybe needs some uh
reevaluation maybe a little bit more
added to it adjusted
but i definitely think the money is the
question
there be no questions thank you for your
testimony
the committee now calls joe hannon
gun owners in new hampshire
uh good afternoon hi members of the
committee uh trying to make this as
painless as possible uh also i know a
few people mentioned earlier that they
are
like some other people mentioned i am
also not a paid lobbyist i'm a volunteer
for gunners of new hampshire as are all
of our
board members and and anyone who works
with our organization
i haven't received any money to any big
money to push any legislation since i
was a state representative
so
anyway thank you um i'll be here all day
seriously i will um
so one thing i'd like to say about this
bill is that this would not nullify any
federal regulations or laws orders or
actions it just means that we're not
going to be complicit in violating the
second amendment rights of people in new
hampshire
that's very simple
i mentioned last week in another
unrelated bill about how new hampshire
has a history of fighting uh
federal rules or regulations that we
just we deemed unjust uh i'm you may
recall i've talked about the fugitive
slave acts
and
new hampshire was actually one of the
states that didn't want to support
putting people in jail or finding people
for violating these and forcing our
courts to to take these those cases
um we didn't win
we had to fight a war over that and the
13th amendment finally did away with
that but this is something very simple
we can do
you may have heard it said it's a
statement it is a statement but it also
is something that that reiterates how
important it is
to
differentiate the federal laws and we're
actually making a stand for our rights
um
it's we heard uh talk about testimony
about how
we won't be able to enforce any federal
regulations or laws
this
and by my reading just says
that it won't uh help with anything
that's inconsistent with any law of the
state regarding specifically regulation
of firearms ammunitions magazines or the
ammunition feeding devices firearms
components firearm supplies or knives
i don't know how a drug
case could be hindered by a
firearm anyway and i don't think that
that would be something that would be
very hard to
get around if they needed to do
something like that if they wanted to do
a drug joint task force or case they
have plenty of things to go after them
for if they in fact are trying to
enforce drug laws you know the
possession of a firearm is usually an
ancillary charge and if that's the only
thing they have
drug dealers and felons aren't supposed
to have a firearm anyway so i don't know
how that would be inconsistent with
state law it would have to be a new
person that they really don't have a
history on uh or record and they don't
have a good case to begin with so i
think that's a bit of a stretch
um
uh i'm not opposed we're not opposed to
any penalties for violation although i
do think that they can be very difficult
to um
legislate and to to uh
to uphold um you'd have to prove that
they were doing it in malice or they
actually had direct knowledge that there
was something involved
i don't think that that would be very
helpful although we're not against it
uh one of the main reasons for doing
something like this isn't just
uh for
just merely federal overreach it could
be something as simple as
there's a there's a ban against a
component that's made in new hampshire
and
if it's not allowed to be sold at the
market at the federal level interstate
commerce could apply but we could still
have it in new hampshire and the feds
couldn't do anything about it
here so
i'd be happy to take any questions and i
do support this bill and i recommend dr
pass
there being no questions thank you for
your testimony
the committee now calls attorney penny
dean
i'm penny dean i'm a concord resident
and i have three points
the first point and i think it's an
important point is what i call scare
tactics oh we're going to lose millions
of dollars oh what are we going to do
well
here's the whole thing
if these government agencies thought
they were going to lose millions of
dollars in grants they're here prepared
to testify on this bill they should have
brought two or three examples here's a
grant
here's the exact wording in the grant
here's the opinion from the attorney
general and not that we might but we
will lose the money of this grant
we will because that's what you need not
maybe
we will
that's number one
number two
i support this bill
with a couple of amendments
and one can be added later one
definitely needs to be added now
and i think the what if part is really
important because if we had all these
speed limit signs on the highways and
they didn't have the green meanies there
with their little radar guns that could
pull you over and give you a ticket how
many people would pay attention to those
signs it's because they know that
somebody can get pulled over and get a
ticket
so if we don't have a what if
in here
then i think this is really nice and
feels good but it's not ultimately going
to help us and the last point to me is
the biggest point which i got a great
chuckle out of it i don't know if all of
you remember but a couple hundred years
ago or so we had kind of a dust up with
the brits over powder
there's no provisions here for
ammunition components powder primer and
brass
needs to be in there
because you can take all our ammo but if
we got powder primer and brass we can
make ammo
that's an important thing
and just as important as firearm
components as ammunition components
and at least the judges that i go before
you'll hear them say all the time the
legislature says what it means and means
what it says we're not going to add
words we're not going to subtract words
and if those specific words aren't in
there they're going to say tough luck
chuck
they'll say it fancier but it's tough
luck chuck
so
i strongly support this bill it's a good
bill
but i think those three things are
things you have to think about powder
primer and brass ammunition components
need to be added in
you can pass it i think the second part
actually needs to have a little if any
terms they have a savings clause here
which is good but terms need to be added
to the savings clause
to make it
as bulletproof as you can make anything
but those are the big issues and i think
the thing that this committee should be
asking people for when they come to you
is if you're going to say these things
might happen we not we've got to know if
they will because you guys are making
really important decisions hopefully to
protect all of us
and some might be scared away by scare
tactics
and i'm happy to answer any questions
there being no questions thank you hold
on
sorry
representative true thank you mr chair
and thank you for taking my question
you were talking about uh
maybe there's a gap of primers
brass and uh and
powder yes
you don't think that comes under firearm
supplies nope or ammunition nope because
ammunition is a loaded cartridge which
contains powder primer and brass i
happen to be an old school as my uncle
would call it custom crafted ammunition
not reloader custom crafted ammunition
and so no i don't think it because
ammunition is a specific thing it's
loaded
thank you yeah sorry i just think you
need to be really clear there
there be no further questions thank you
for your testimony
at this point there be no one else to
testify i'm going to close the public
hearing
on hp
1178 and the committee will stand in
recess until 1 30.
we're going to probably do a
subcommittee on this
thank you
okay
oh
oh um
that's why i like hanging out with these
kids
do nothing because of the uh
[Music]
members of your president take your
seats
in in respect to the subcommittee
hearings
and this this is the members on the
committee
i did i did establish three
subcommittees today
if the members wish to schedule a
subcommittee hearing
uh
those are going to be chaired by
representative roy but just
please communicate with the
chair that those subcommittees so we can
actually schedule those properly we
don't have the free will to schedule
hearings as we wish
so it doesn't look like we actually will
have anything scheduled next wednesday
we will have a light
day on friday so i would anticipate
there being some subcommittee hearings
that can be worked into that day as well
representative true
ah thank you mr chair i got i think i
got two 15 40 and 12 66 what was the
other one
uh hb 1215
is also a subcommittee
hb
1215 that is relative to the definition
of a residual amount
in the controlled drug act
and i'm also going to
establish a subcommittee on house bill
1127 that is relative
to exonerations and annulments
yes
representative roy do it you're going to
be appointed as a chair of that
subcommittee
i'll appoint representative welch
and representative wallace
to the sub to that subcommittee along
with representative conley and
representative muse
representative muse i've appointed you
to the subcommittee for hb 1127.
1127. you were not here for the public
hearing on that but i do know
it's a similar bill we had last term so
i assume you'll be familiar with the
subject matter
and these will be noticed
they would need to be noticed
and just the members understand in all
likelihood it would be those would be
scheduled in the day that were here for
public hearings as well
at this time we are now going to open
the public hearing on house bill
prohibiting the display of a deadly
weapon
at a parade funeral
picket line march rally
or demonstration
this time the chair recognizes
representative muse to introduce the
bill
thank you mr chair
like many people in new hampshire over
the years i have joined protests and
rallies for causes i believe in
i'm sure many of the folks in this room
have joined protests marches and
demonstrations
for the causes that they believe in as
well one of the most precious rights we
have as citizens is our first amendment
right to raise our voices in protest or
in support of changes that we as
citizens would like to see
protecting this right and ensuring that
people are free to speak out at rallies
and demonstrations without the fear of
intimidation
is the very act of protecting our
democracy itself
the last five years have brought us
extreme division that has angered
frustrated and sad many of us
but one of the worst trends the last
five years has brought us
is the increasing presence of firearms
being openly displayed during protests
since the start of 2020
weapons toting protesters and
counter-protesters have been spotted at
demonstrations in portsmouth concord
nashua and manchester
governor sununu was also forced to
cancel his 2021 inaugural ceremony after
armed anti-mask demonstrators marched
outside his home in newfields
in other parts of the country protesters
and counterprotesters have died in
gunfire in places like kenosha
portland austin and las vegas
but these events are just the tip of the
iceberg
according to the armed conflict location
and event data project a group that
collects data and reports on political
violence worldwide
over 610
armed demonstrations have been reported
around the country since the start of
2020.
the group also reports that armed
demonstrations are 6.5 times more likely
to turn violent or destructive than
demonstrations where no firearms are
present
hb 1151 is a bill that seeks to protect
first amendment rights
second amendment rights
and most important of all human lives
hb 1151 would ban the open carrying of
firearms within 100 feet of a protest
rally march or any first amendment
related activity that takes place on
public property
despite what you may have been told the
right to self-defense is preserved under
this bill
while the bill does restrict open carry
and protest it has a pres it has a
specific exemption for concealed carry
so if being armed makes you feel safer
you can carry a weapon
but what you can't do is carry it out in
the open within 100 feet of other people
expressing their first amendment rights
currently seven states along with the
district of columbia bar firearms and
rallies
among those states are alabama and north
carolina
over the years our courts have
repeatedly ruled that it does not
violate the second amendment for the
government to prohibit firearms at
public events
here in new hampshire
we prohibit firearms from our own courts
the u.s supreme court has made it clear
in its 2008 decision uh district
columbia versus heller that the second
amendment and i quote
is not a right to keep and carry any
weapon whatsoever in any manner
whatsoever and for whatever purpose
the supreme court has left the door open
for governments to impose reasonable
safety restrictions on the possession
and use of firearms
the courts have also upheld prohibitions
on carrying firearms on government
government property
which suggests that state and local
governments can lawfully restrict the
carrying of firearms during public
events on public property such as public
parks streets and other government owned
land where demonstrations rallies and
marches typically take place
some would say that displaying weapons
itself is an allowable exercise in free
speech
but the right to free speech cannot be
confused with the right to terrorize
others and threaten public safety
though some may attempt to defend the
display of firearms in polling places as
free speech
decades of legal precedent make it clear
that that would simply not be the case
the constitutional right to bear arms uh
and the right to free speech
does not inten do not
does not
i'm sorry does not permit intimidation
with deadly weapons
the point is is that guns don't speak
although they may they may command
attention and they may command fear
the objects themselves are not
inherently expressive
people are expressive
there is nothing in this bill that
restricts anyone's freedom of speech and
there is nothing in this bill
that restricts anyone's second amendment
rights
concealed carry continues to be allowed
if you want to bring a gun
into a polling into a protest
for uh for self-defense reasons you can
do that
there's nothing in this bill that would
prohibit that
the bottom line is that hb 1151 offers
us a way to protect the safety and the
rights of citizens engaged in first
amendment activities while also
protecting their right to self-defense
i urge you to give it an ought to pass
recommendation
i will take any questions the committee
has
representative burt you were recognized
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
you know when we have an open carry
rally for guns people open carry their
guns but then i'm looking at the funeral
procession
i'm hoping it's 40 45 years from now
but
when the day comes and i kick the bucket
i'm assuming there's going to be a lot
of people there with open carry guns
because i open carry how are they going
to go through a funeral possession
and if there was a rally in my name
people showed up you know how are they
going to dis you know show their second
amendment rights
display because that's what i support
the bill does create an exception
for
organizations that are authorized to uh
to carry weapons uh during things like
parades um and funerals
uh and in thing also in things like
honor guards
so i believe that is taken care of
representative burt recognized for a
follow-up
thank you mr chairman um i read the bill
i could you tell me which line that's on
because i don't see where i would be
exempt
i did see the part where
the
you know for the parade
and thank you
under exemptions in section 2
this subdivision shall not apply to
federal law enforcement officers
sheriffs police officers or other duly
appointed peace and other law
enforcement officers when on duty
nor to the regular
and
nor to the regular uh
printing out off the page here nor did
the print no to the regular and it looks
like ordinary uh pistols or revolvers as
merchandise nor the members of the armed
services of the united states when on
when on duty
nor to the national guard went on duty
nor to duly authorized military police
or civil organizations or serving in
honor guides at funerals
uh thank you but it still exempts me
and my friends
i would say your your 24 gun salute
representative is safe
representative
thank you for taking my question and
thank you for your testimony
on the first page i'm focusing on lines
22-23 where it says this section shall
apply regardless of whether or not a
permit has been secured by the event
organizer
is what is the rationale for
not requiring a permit i'm sorry i'm
having a hard time hearing your uh
it it's my understanding of what the
bill says is that if there is any type
of demonstration this law would be in
effect
but it applies to
demonstrations where there was no permit
pulled whether
even in situations where the law would
would require a permit
for that organism that demonstration
so i'm asking what's the what's the
rationale for excluding the permit
requirement for the organization
in new hampshire if you if you take a
look at
the way demonstrations work for instance
in my community in portsmouth
a permit is not required to have a
demonstration it's a good idea
and it's always a good idea to contact
the police department before you do
something like that but it's not always
required in every case in every
municipality
so the goal is to make sure that people
who would be
you know who would be exercising their
first amendment rights in situations
where there wasn't a permit also
are protected against intimidation as
well so that's the goal of the bill
thank you
it's time the representative is excused
the committee now calls representative
timothy horrigan
well thank you very much i'm
representing timothy jorge from stratfor
county district six which is the towns
of durham and matberry and i'm a
i'm a co-sponsor of this bill and i i
support it
we've seen in uh
especially in 2020 we saw a number of
really disturbing incidents with people
uh with
armed counter protesters threatening
peaceful peaceful protesters
you know it's
people who aren't used to being around
openly carried weapons um
are
afraid of them they find that
intimidating and you may say that's
reasonable or not but
certainly the physical danger is
is real um this
doesn't do anything to
both encounter demonstrators spectators
and protest alike and still
can still conceal carry and we're
constitutional carry stage you don't
actually need a permit to do this you
can still conceal carry
for your protection or for whatever
other reason you feel you need to need a
protest and um
and although this bill is uh
it's a little bit confusingly written
but there is uh an exception for
first of all uh pro second amendment
demonstrations or also if you have an
honor guard it doesn't have to be a
government
organization it can just be uh you know
any civil organization you can have a
you can have
rifles hopefully unloaded or loaded with
blanks for
for uh to be carried at that offense so
i think this uh
balances the first and second amendment
uh second amendment rights and
actually as a point of order i notice
when the members of the committee is
wearing a pro-second amendment
this probably playing a pro-second
amendment hat on the one hand i think
all of us those who oppose and they'll
support the bill recognize that there is
a second amendment excuse me
the representative will suspend their
testimony yeah
i you're testifying as a representative
but also as a member of the public
you're not permitted to make a point of
order oh i'm sorry with your testimony
i'll just point out that but you may you
may continue with your testimony as it
relates to the bill and that that is it
okay so that's
i think it'll avoid a lot of uh
and we've had some some uh some some
tragic incidents either with uh you know
people
infiltrating the march and doing violent
things although only rarely shooting or
we also had a tragic incident in
wisconsin where
a young man well he went down
his goal was to uh somehow protect
someone from the protesters and then he
ended up
killing
killing two people and um you know he
was acquitted and i understand why he
was acquitted but still that was a
tragic thing which i think we had to be
less likely to happen in new hampshire
if we had that law because it's uh
never never a good thing when anyone
gets shot and killed regardless of what
the motivations of the shooter wear so
that's um
anyway that
um and another thing that happened we
often have people coming out and
supposedly assisting the police and
we've had that even here in new
hampshire we had
although a photo was only one incident
out of
many there's the somewhat disturbing
issue of uh
some young man who had some sort of
unofficial material militia
paraphernalia kind of doing a little bit
of fist bump with the state policeman
and that certainly
created at least in some people
eyes the uh
the perception that the state police
were biased against the protesters even
though i mean that probably was not the
case but it did sort of look that way
with the picture so we'd have fewer
embarrassing pictures like that so
that's uh
anyway i mean i'm in favor of the bill
and uh
and i apologize for you having to
reprimand me understand that too so
thanks
but
but there is a member of wearing a
second amendment hat and i don't think
anybody
can go just interested with with risk
with respect to
your testimony please
i've already warned you about this
you're can you you want to make an
objection
it has to come from a member of the
committee okay you're not you're not a
member of the committee yes you're
testifying before the committee about
the bill being introduced to the
committee that is what your your
testimonies be limited to okay
so can i
say like why i think this bill does not
conflict it's a second amendment
yeah so
the second amendment merely says it's
infringing the right to bear arms i
don't believe that this
i think this
bill doesn't infringe on the right right
right to bear arms which is not absolute
and also it uh
helps
our right to free speech is guaranteed
in the first amendment and like many
other and
in our own state constitution so thanks
so if you haven't haven't answered any
questions should anybody have any
representative drew
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question um
in testimony you know people have said
that this this is to
help improve uh the safety of of the
public yeah
how how is the public how would the
public be more safe
if i'm carrying a knife
in my poc in my
concealed
versus i'm carrying a knife not
concealed how does that make them more
more safe
well
i mean it creates a more confrontive
situation um you know if the protesters
start yelling back at the counter
protesters vice versa if somebody has a
you know a rifle especially a loaded one
that uh just they're up the ante makes
people more makes emotions run higher
and then there is the possibility
somebody might
might
use their weapon and then or have some
other forms of violence and then also um
you know but then the concealed carry
that's just not as confrontive so like
until you pull it out nobody nobody
knows you have it so it's uh
it
won't uh it's not like won't
pour gasoline on the flames of an
already tense situation as much as open
carried one would thank you thank you
thank you representative for your
testimony
the committee now calls representative
all children
and you've got written testimony
you have written testimony for the
committee
thank you
thank you mr chairman thank you
committee
house bill
1151 is a bill about the coercive
control of those people who are seeking
to negatively influence the freedom of
speech
and the freedom of assembly by other
granite staters
if a person goes walking through the
aisles of the market basket carrying a
baseball bat around not hitting anything
not necessarily coming near anyone
not saying anything maybe just
striding through the aisles and carrying
it on their shoulder
do you think that kind of behavior
will cause alarm of course it will
because a baseball bat is something that
is unusual to carry around the
supermarket it is not normal it's
alarming and it should be
let's say you go to a restaurant and the
person at the next table
pulls out a ten and three quarter inch
whaling knife
you know the survival knife with the
serrated edge and the gut hook
so they put it and they just put it on
the table for everyone to see
why on earth would they do that
ostensibly everything in the restaurant
is already dead
and the restaurant
provides their own cutlery
it's an unusual item to bring into a
restaurant and put on the table that is
an alarming situation it should be
these instances are examples of coercive
control they are actions
taken that send a message to the people
around them
that the balance of power is in their
favor because they have introduced an
item that is unusual to its surroundings
and circumstances
and they have demonstrated a
comfortableness with threatening
that is coercive control
neither one of these situations are
normal behavior we wouldn't accept it
interestingly enough though no coalition
of baseball enthusiasts plan events to
normalize the use of bats in places
other than baseball games
there are no campaigns by hunting knife
companies to byok
trying to normalize bringing your own
knives to restaurants
but this year but every year this
legislature hears bills that seek to
normalize the presence of firearms
everywhere
bring your gun to pick up a pizza bring
your gun to your kids ballet class bring
your gun to the library bring your gun
to dinner bring your gun to your house
of worship bring your gun to work and of
course
why not bring your gun to someone else's
funeral domestic violence vigil
celebratory parade
or via or as i have experienced gun
violence prevention rally
this type of behavior is all in an
effort to normalize the presence of the
most lethal means of coercive control in
our communities
this bill
seeks to affirm that coercive control by
lethal means is not something we want to
normalize in new hampshire coercive
control creates unequal power dynamics
in a relationship
it is a form of violence
it is a key factor
in domestic abuse and intimate partner
violence it is a part of the pattern of
behaviors
that perpetrators of coercive control
use to gain
power and control over their situations
coercive control is an act of
intimidation it is a silent threat it
breaks down boundaries and it threatens
safety
when someone has a firearm they don't
need to wave it around its presence is a
threat alone
ask any victim of domestic violence
whose abuser never pointed a weapon at
them but would take it out and leave it
on the kitchen table as a warning
ask the victim whose date ended in
sexual assault why they froze when the
weapon came out of the glove compartment
just for show ask someone who's attended
a gun violence prevention rally why they
scurried back to their car
because counter protesters showed up
with their rifles
ask the family members who lost lost a
loved one to gun violence how normal it
feels
to be around people who to their
knowledge
have no permit no training and for all
anyone knows no background check and
acquiring that weapon because private
sales don't require it in new hampshire
i'll share with you that those are all
people i have worked with and the
presence of a gun
has improved none of those situations
normalizing the presence of firearms in
all parts of our lives
is the goal of many gun enthusiast
lobbyists here in new hampshire because
it sells
more firearms
the rise of white supremacy groups here
in new hampshire is undeniable
they have harassed school board members
at school board meetings in nashua
they attend select board meetings in
danville
they threaten theater goers in
portsmouth
they are seeking to normalize the
presence of guns everywhere all the time
we should not endeavor to normalize the
abusive act of coercive control
we have an obligation to the citizens of
new hampshire to create safe communities
free from abuse
article 2 of the new hampshire
constitution ensures all persons have
the right to keep and bear arms in
defense of themselves their families
their property and the state
often glossed over though is article 1
that states our government is founded in
consent and for the general good
living under the threat of coercive
control in no way contributes to the
common good
house bill 1151
seeks to create some sacred space for
the ability to use our first amendment
rights of speech
and assemble to rally
mourn and grieve without the inherently
coercive control of displays of weaponry
as a counter protest
signal of possible further violence or
threat i respectfully ask you to please
vote
otp on house bill 195 i'm sorry one one
five one thank you
thank you for your testimony the chair
may inquire with a question and i i see
that the witness is a co-sponsor of the
bill
on page two
lines
uh
four and five
creates an exception for when this law
would apply
what was the rationale for
creating this presumption for an
exception for a pickup truck only
but excluding other other types of
vehicles
i'm sorry you're asking why
the co-authors of the bill
did not want to include people who put
hunting racks in their house in their in
their own cars it it seems to only apply
to a pickup truck
i'm wondering why if there was a
specific reason to allow a pickup truck
to fall under the
exception but not other types of
vehicles
i'm sorry mr chairman i'm aware i'm not
aware of any kind of vehicle that also
accommodates a gun rack in it other than
pickup trucks is there another one i'm
i'm unaware of that
if that is if that is the sticking point
i'm sure that the co-sponsors would be
happy to create an amendment to address
that particular those particular lines
i was just asking if there was a reason
for having a pickup truck under the
exception but not a van for example
again if there is if that's the sticking
point we will happily make the exception
we will happily write an amendment
um
to clarify that and would welcome your
input on making that amendment
absolutely
thank you for taking my question
certainly
thank you representative testament
you're recognized for a question
we're talking about
fear and trepidation
around firearms
wouldn't a better way
be
of
having a good firearm safety course
as part of the school curriculum we have
all sorts of other safety courses to
keep
kids fear
from you know being exacerbated by
whatever the item is
what i mean
would there be a place
in our schools
to educate them how not to be afraid of
them rather than just oh it's bad
thank you for the question
representative testerman as far as
firearm awareness in
our schools
i should think that
if there were
some curriculum that would
help
students understand
what coercive control is and how deadly
firearms are
and how they do not improve
situations where people are exercising
their free speech that would probably be
a very welcome addition to curriculum
representative testimony recognized for
a follow-up
but what you're saying
and what i want to know isn't that just
really
reinforcing your feelings about the
firearms and not educating the children
so if i understand you correctly
when
when people
come to a come to a funeral rally parade
for instance like the
the evening vigil that we hold
in october for
domestic violence victims or the gun
violence prevention rallies that we have
held
and when counter protesters show up
with multiple firearms and
weapons all over them
um
that we it's our fault for feeling
intimidated by that coercive control
because i don't know that i think that
the most appropriate thing would be to
teach people not to threaten and
intimidate their
fellow granite staters who are
exercising their first amendment rights
representative burt you're recognized
for a question
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
if you or somebody else is so afraid why
won't they carry a gun for protection
so i think what you're asking me is that
why don't we have more guns everywhere
for everyone
and
the purpose of this legislation
is to create spaces for people to grieve
mourn rally
in places where their choice
not to carry a firearm is not
um
is is acknowledged and that they are not
threatened with the coercive control
of
groups of people or even just one person
as has happened right here on the steps
in concord who show up
with multiple firearms to create
um
to create a you know a space that is
wildly unsafe
thank you
thank you for your testimony thank you
the representative is excused
the committee now calls representative
greg huff
thank you mr chairman and members
honorable members of the criminal
justice and public safety committee
i rise to oppose this bill
um
hearing the testimony previously
there's
so many ways
to address the concerns
um
i'd like to uh i heard a lot of
anecdotal stories so i'd like to quickly
just hit one i know i said i would be
only two minutes but
i'm gonna be a bit longer
um
when it comes
to parades
funerals pickets
lines marches
rallies demonstrations i've been to all
of these things
and in my life i don't understand why it
is
that i would have to give up
my fundamental god-given right to
protect myself my family my friends in
my state because i want to go to some
place because somebody else has a
pathological fear
of something
i i got a quick example it was mentioned
out here earlier of some rallies
at the state house with a lot of folks
at guns i've been to a couple of these
they range from 300 to 700 people
it is the most polite
well-articulated
day you will ever see
everybody there is a very very nice i
have never seen anybody intimidated by
anything
so
i guess my question is
for myself
you know when you walk down a hall and
it's just you and one other person
and one of you has to move
so that the other one can get by
why is it that we're the ones that
always have to move
why do we have to give up our freedom
and our right for somebody
else i just doesn't make sense
i'll end with this
article two of the new hampshire
constitution
the bearing of arms all persons have the
right to keep and bear arms in defense
of themselves their families their
property and the state
this is not location specific
thank you for your time and i'll take
any questions
bradley you're recognized for a question
thank you chairman and thank you for
taking my question
so you're saying that
you want your rights as a gun owner
to supersede
my rights if i attended an event to not
have guns present
so you're saying that
you all have to move over
and make way for us
but it doesn't sound like that's what
you're trying to do it sounds like the
other way around is that correct
i'm saying that i have
an inherent right as a human being to be
able to protect myself
what other folks want to do or not do is
up to them
but i should not be
barred from the state
to carry any place i have a legal right
to be
represented bradley recognized for a
follow-up thank you
so do i have the right to attend an
event without guns present given that
this bill itself says that if you want
to have a rally
a second amendment rally you're able to
do that so if i wanted to go to the
library with my children and have like a
little rally outside saying we want
books here do you think it's okay for me
to be able to go there
without the presence of guns
or do you still think
that your right to carry arms supersedes
my right
to not want them there
thank you for the question
if you want to go someplace
and you want to
i believe what you're saying is it would
be akin to me basically going into your
home if you don't want something in your
home then that's fine if you want to go
to a library event and you have it
pre-ordained that there's not going to
be anything there that's fine that's up
to you
but
it if i'm going to go anywhere on earth
i have the right to defend myself and
you know
all kidding aside on this one
if you're going to be in a spot
where
potentially something bad can happen
i'm not going to subject
you
or the gentleman in front here or the
people here to that danger if there's an
option to stop that danger
why would i not
allow folks to be able to do that
so an answer to your question it's not a
chance to make somebody else not do
something
your safety
isn't
paramount to my right
representative roy
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um and you can answer this if you're
aware of it or not
um
because i'm not um could you tell me
where in new hampshire or the united
states constitution that it mentions
baseball bats
it does not as far as i'm aware oh thank
you okay
thank you for the question
thank you representative for your
testimony thank you mr chairman and
thank you honorable members of the
committee
the committee now calls joe hannon
gun owners of new hampshire
good afternoon thank you for hearing me
again my name is joe hennen from gun
owners of new hampshire
we stand in support of this bill 1151
we don't think that
criminal threatening should be allowed
it should obviously be prosecuted but
just the mere presence of an inanimate
object is not threatening and it
shouldn't be considered criminal
activity we heard someone earlier say
that this is intimidation
and also right after that they said
people are expressive and guns are not
well they're not and we can't say that
if they're not expressive we're going to
consider just the mere presence of one
being a crime
you're allowed to have one according to
this bill so it's okay to have as many
as you want inside your code inside your
pants
i'm not really sure what the purpose is
other if unless i'm not questioning the
the motives of the bill but i don't
understand why
banning just the presence of a gun
would influence the person who's holding
the firearm or other weapon in any way
unless they're worried about i'm not
sure if people are worried about being
starting a confrontation and people
don't like someone like we heard
reference to the incident in wisconsin
you know whether that individual had a
firearm concealed or not would have made
a difference we don't know but the fact
is
that
that person had a firearm and used it to
defend themselves and was acquitted in
court under self-defense
so
i'm also not really sure whether we can
differentiate
what
a true riot is versus a political
event or protest so when do we draw the
line there's nothing in here that says
okay this protest is now in a hand it's
not a riot so you you could have your
firearm uh people may recall and a long
time ago not some of the younger ones
won't remember but 92 and the la riots
there were korean store owners who were
on their rooftops with with rifles to
keep their their stores from burning
down
now there was they were eventually
declared riots during that period but
initially there were protests
you know when do you draw the line
the pickup truck was a good example i do
want to say that there are many ways of
other vehicles that can have racks or a
system of holding a
firearm most police cars
are sedans or something similar and they
have a shotgun rack or other gun racks
in the front seat or even on the back
it's not uncommon i've seen a prius with
a gun wreck so
you know it could be anything
um
this it says this shall not apply to
federal law enforcement officers
sheriffs police officers or other duly
appointed peace law enforcement officers
went on duty
i'm not really sure if that means that
if they're off duty that a police
officer is not allowed to carry a
firearm even though they are allowed to
carry
net with national reciprocity if they
meet requirements while off duty so if
they're off duty does that not apply to
them
it also says that
the regular and ordinary transportation
epistles or revolvers as merchandise
is uh
does not apply here so what does that
mean does it mean if you just bought it
it's okay but if you bought it a month
ago and it's still in your car you
brought it with you put on your seat or
in a holster near your dash then you
would be in violation of the law
also there's no exception for being
within 100 feet
of a protest if you're in your car and
you're at a stoplight or if you turn a
corner in a city and they just happen to
be protesting on the other side of the
corner and you didn't know it was there
um you know you can be surprised and you
would be in
violation um
i i heard references to you know uh
different things that could be
considered offensive
uh you know just because something's
offensive doesn't mean it needs to be
against the law i don't think we should
amend this to add fist bumps is
something that shouldn't be allowed with
public officials at a at a public
gathering i mean that's you have a
problem with that take it up with the
department
um and how do we ban
threatening images
if you have a group of people who are
maybe not as big as another group if one
group just happens to be bigger that
could be threatening to some you know do
you say well we can't have a disparity
of size differences or age differences
if you have a group of elderly people
protesting you know do you not little
but you know what if there's and this is
purely ridiculous but what if you have
some other group that is uh you know
larger or stronger seeming showing up do
you want is that not scary to that
individual or that group it may be but
there's no reason to make something
illegal because of someone's perceived
differences
and and the bottom line is if you can
carry concealed at a protest or a
funeral or anywhere else you've got the
weapon on you if someone's angering you
so much that you're going to shoot and
kill them you already have the means to
do that it seems that this is more
likely to stop someone else from
provoking someone with a firearm which i
do understand so do we want to make
poking poking the bear so to speak
against the law
it's not a good idea i don't recommend
it but people do have a right to defend
themselves whether it's openly or
concealed carry i don't think we need to
have laws that deal with just pure
emotions and not facts criminal
threatening should be prosecuted and the
mere presence of an object is not
threatening nor criminal so i please ask
you to itl this bill
representative harry catherine
um
i'm sorry i can't hear you
i apologize you mentioned that you are
part of
um gun owners of new hampshire is that
an off site of
gun owners of america
uh
we're not an affiliate organization
technically we're we're not we're an
independent organization we're in new
hampshire gunners of new hampshire we're
an nra state affiliate but that doesn't
mean we're an organization of the nra
we're just
so you're not affiliated with gun owners
of america is that what you just said
not not officially affiliated we discuss
things with them from time like anybody
like any other group
yeah
representative harry gathering
recognized for a follow-up okay um
are you familiar with um
the gun owners of america have supported
the militia movement across the united
states
what do you mean
the militia movements what about it are
you aware that they have supported it
the militia movements across the united
states oh
mr uh mr chairman i'm not sure i
understand representative
what does this have to do with the bill
representative
you have to be recognized to speak
unless you're
making a point of order
you know i'm not sure
it sounds familiar but i don't know what
it has to do with anything
okay well then i'll ask the next
question
and
last fall but just i remind the members
of the committee that the questions we
ask the members of the public
testifying with their testifying
individual
individually or on behalf of an
organization is for information relating
to the bill
so let's try to
narrow the scope with questions
but you were recognized for follow-up
well there's no need for it because i do
know that he understands what i'm saying
so
i'm just going to drop it at this point
um
point of order mr speaker or mr chair
representative klein knight you
recognized for your point of voted
police state your point of order
um i would argue that
a representative from a certain
affiliation
has every right to be questioned on his
ties and credibility on a subject matter
related to this and that
representative harriet gathering be
allowed to
address and get a clear answer for her
question thank you
well
two things number one your point of
order is
not right you needed to have raised it
right when i made that statement but in
respect to the member who i addressed
that comment to
um i don't believe i actually stopped or
prohibited that member from asking the
question i just it was getting close to
that boundary line so i was just kind of
as a reminder
to my to my colleague
representative kline do you have a
question for the witness
you recognize for a question
thank you
thank you so much mr chair um i just one
i'm wondering uh if
if everybody's concerned is that they're
so scared of the first amendment that
that
will outweigh their right
and they go right to a second amendment
are they
they can't control themselves when they
listen to people's first amendments is
this is this the concern so that we need
to outweigh the first amendment by
pushing the second amendment for a
peaceful protest
absolutely not that they're both they're
both vital and important and
i was just
i think i was just hypothesizing that
maybe some people
you know wanted this to protect
themselves
because they can't control themselves
when they see a firearm not the other
way around the person has a firearm has
it whether it's open or concealed so
they've got the gun
it's not a matter of them having the
ability to cause harm if they chose to
they often choose not to unless they're
in danger or being threatened or
physically indeed you know
life-threatening
situations you recognize for a follow-up
are you saying that people are so
threatened by first amendment rights
that that is why they need to carry a
gun around
they're so threatened by the freedom of
speech that they feel the need to carry
a weapon
why would i say that i
i believe you just i don't want to
debate i'm just i'm not sure i've ever
even insinuated that i think they're
both equally important one does not
override the other they're completely
separate entities that shouldn't
contradict each other in any situation
especially in a bill like this
i believe that you you're saying that
you represented representative knight
cleric
the member will suspend and i'm going to
instruct the witness ought to respond to
that if you have a follow-up question
please raise your hand and as you can
tell i've been recognizing every member
to speak that there's no need for
yelling out questions without being
recognized
so let's just
representative conley you're recognized
to ask a question thank you mr chairman
and thank you for taking the question so
i think the premise of this bill
as i understand it is that the presence
of a firearm could be used
by bad actors to
threaten implicitly other people
we all everyone in this room knows what
the law is on constitutional carry on
open carry that's not i don't think for
a debate here but how would a reasonable
person or could a reasonable person
distinguish between
someone exercising one's right and one
going beyond that right to use the
presence of a firearm to threaten could
could that distinction be made
perception is relative to any individual
but that shouldn't be what we base law
on
you know if something's legal it's legal
it shouldn't be illegal when someone
chooses it not to be for their own
political purposes say for example
there's a protest interior specifically
does not allow counter protests or
protests that firearms within 100 feet
of another protest
well that doesn't preclude the
non-lethal weapon or firearm owning
group from having
confrontations within 100 feet they can
get closer and what do you have to keep
backing up and backing up but all of a
sudden your voice isn't heard
you can have one group
use their first amendment as a cudgel
against another person's first amendment
right and that's exactly what this kind
of legislation could do
thank you for your testimony the
witnesses the witness is excused
the committee now calls alan rice
good afternoon members of the committee
for the record
my name is alan rice i am a resident of
bedford new hampshire
i'm here on behalf of gun owners of
america a national
organization with over 2 million members
and supporters nationwide
rather than read from my testimony which
is intended to cover
this bill and one that you're going to
hear later today i'd like to offer some
remarks in response to what some of the
sponsors had to say
representative muse seems to be
concerned about weapons toting
protesters
well people have been carrying firearms
in new hampshire for somewhere around
300 years
and no one should have to forfeit their
second amendment rights
to exercise their first amendment rights
because certain people are uncomfortable
around guns
that doesn't mean everyone else
loses their right to have a gun
kenosha was mentioned
the gentleman in kenosha the young adult
was found not guilty
that was actually a case that we
reviewed extensively
we're very involved in use of force
issues
when the adult
a physically large adult male started
swinging his skateboard and using it as
a deadly weapon that skateboard was no
longer a toy it was a deadly weapon and
mr rittenhouse responded absolutely
appropriately and we're glad that the
jury agreed with him
new hampshire has a long history of not
making crimes
out of carrying guns it's never been a
crime to carry a gun in the open in new
hampshire ever
and since 2017 it's not been a crime to
carry a gun concealed
without a license
i would say that this long 300-year
track record shows that the majority of
residents
agree with that
there's no clamor for change i would say
that the sponsors of this bill
are not only the outliers they're part
of a tiny
minority they mentioned seven states
most of the seven states that prohibit
the carrying of guns at parades and
protests and funerals
are in the deep south
the deep south did not allow people to
carry guns until the mid 1990s
it was a lot of jim crow laws that had
to be overturned there was a lot of
legislative compromise and deal making
and one of the deals that was made
in
multiple states was off limits places
for concealed carry
new hampshire's concealed carry law
predated most of the southern states by
about 70 years
we've always carried firearms without
restriction
these restrictions were concessions
so people could get the ability to carry
guns at least some of the time
for new hampshire to adopt the
provisions of house bill 1151 would
actually be going backwards
backwards in our history and i don't
think anybody
in this general court wants to do that
i want to respond to representative all
chiller and i've said this before in
other hearings coercive control
there's absolutely nothing
that prevents a victim or someone who
thinks she might be a victim from
legally arming herself for self-defense
it's not coercive control if someone's
peacefully carrying a weapon
i'm peacefully carrying a weapon right
now but because we're in this particular
room in this building i can't take my
coat off if we were in your committee
room i would take my coat off to show
that it's a normal activity for people
in new hampshire to do every day
people get dressed wallet car keys
reading glasses gun
knife it's just people go about their
daily business it's perfectly normal
we're not seeking to normalize anything
it's already normal
we're seeking to persuade the
legislature not to go backwards so i
respectfully disagree with
representative all chiller
and i would ask this committee to vote
house bill 1151 in expedient to
legislate
representative bert you're recognized
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
your testimony
if you look at page one of the bill and
it's line 24 and 25
and let me read it to you
it's very short
this section shall also apply to a
person in a private vehicle who is who
are part or traveling that's the word i
like is traveling on a public property
within a hundred feet
of the closest event
as i travel down a road how would i know
that there's an event coming up
and what would i do with my firearm at
that point would i have to stop and turn
around or you know how would i handle
that situation
oh representative i appreciate that
question
this is a very serious section because
cars are mobile and i've seen a lot of
protests in parades that are mobile
and when the two come upon one another
the person with a openly carried firearm
in a vehicle
would be in violation of this they could
face arrest and jail time
for what for having a gun and not using
it and not harming anyone
it's kind of absurd on its face but i
think that that
those two lines
um clearly show the intentions of the
sponsors
which is to
delegitimize firearms stigmatize those
who use them and ultimately ban their
ownership and use throughout our state
thank you
representative klein knight you're
recognized
thank you chair
uh thank you to the witness for taking
my question are you saying your right to
have a gun at a peaceful protest
outweighs the safety of the people
weaponless at that protest
my right to have a gun
is my right to have a gun
my right and the practice of carrying a
gun
does not put anyone in any danger other
than the person who might try to harm me
i'm carrying a gun right now
representative do you feel unsafe i
haven't made any threatening movements
and i have no plans to do so
and i can tell you there's many other
people in this room carrying firearms
that doesn't make anyone unsafe to the
contrary makes people safer
thank you for your testimony oh
representative harry catherine
you're recognized
thank you chair and thank you for taking
my question
you heard in testimony that
gun owners of new hampshire is
unaffiliated with gun owners of america
are you aware that the gun owners of new
hampshire's testimony sheet has uh gun
owners of america on it
i i haven't seen it i'm sure dr hannan
would provide
but i haven't seen it
thank you
you're welcome
thank you for your testimony the witness
is excused
the committee now calls rosanne chester
thank you committee chair thank you
committee members for allowing me to
speak i've heard a lot of talk today
well actually i want to start with i
want to start with dispelling some
misnomer i was one of those protesters
at the governor's house
i did see over 20 weapons visibly
available uh readily available but i did
not see one of those weapons unless on
the less than 10 protesters all of those
weapons over 20 of them were on the on
the hips of the police officers
so i just wanted to dispel that rumor
and i really appreciate being able to
have the venue to finally clear that up
um i heard a lot of talk today about
that four letter word
four-letter word that that is i'm
hearing more and more and more since
covert 19 fear
the bottom line is is if a bill like
this were to pass
then we
are opening opening ourselves up for
oh my goodness they're not wearing a
mask we must be afraid
they're not they don't have a vaccine
passport we must be afraid
it is not fair or appropriate to
identify people
for
who they are or what they represent
based on the color of their skin the way
they choose to carry a weapon or not
choose a carrier weapon their sex their
political affiliation their religious
affiliation or their or their um vaccine
vaccine status
and the bottom line here is i have
listened to a lot of representatives
talk about they want vaccine mandates
they want mass mandates and then they
turn around and they come in here and
they try to take our second amendment
rights away
i think that is a problem thank you and
i'm open to any questions
thank you for your testimony the witness
is excused
the committee now calls lauren lepage
association
good afternoon once again my name is
lauren lepage i'm from sanford maine
i'm here as the state director for the
national rifle association in new
hampshire
i will submit a letter electronically to
the committee covering both this and the
following bill because our rationale in
for opposition is largely based on the
same
rationale so i'll save you from having
to hear from me twice
um
i think joe i think alan i think
everyone has summed it up
simply open carrying a firearm
should not be something that's made
illegal i do want to talk about the
mechanics of enforcement of the bill
it wouldn't be difficult to sort of
hypothetically assume
that a parade is moving and so people
are going to be moving in and out of
that 100 foot buffer zone as the parade
is moving in a public way
that could result in someone who was law
abiding
not a spectator of the event not
participating in a counter protest
potentially getting hung up in the
system while they were having a
conversation with their neighbor on the
sidewalk simply because they were open
carrying a firearm
another thing is with a blazer
if my blazer accidentally gets stuck and
my firearm becomes visible despite the
fact that i was attempting to carry
concealed
does that entrap a law-abiding
citizen who is lawfully carrying a
firearm concealed
so to not repeat all of the points that
had been made
those are some sort of the mechanical
issues with the bill that we've seen
um and like i said i will submit written
testimony on both of these for the
committee to consider
thank you
thank you for your testimony
the witness is excused
the committee now calls penny dean
my name is penny dean i'm a resident of
concord new hampshire
and i would ask that this bill be itl
for many many reasons
and it's not because i want to sell guns
i don't sell guns for a living so i'm
not here to sell guns i'd like to buy
guns more guns but not sell
next i think again we need to go back to
the dictionary it's a very basic tool
the term coercive control
has been used repeatedly if one looks to
the dictionary in the history
it's defined as harm punishment and
threaten
is designed to harm punish and threaten
anyone
i don't think anyone can make a
reasonable argument that those who are
carrying open firearms are trying to
harm punish or threaten another person
because if they are we've got plenty of
laws to take care of them
but i think what's important and i think
you have to look at this
a person who doesn't carry a gun i find
strange
because carrying a gun if there's a
message that you're carrying openly
sends i'll tell you what message i'm
sending that i am responsible for my own
personal safety i don't expect anyone
else to buy my groceries i have a job i
make money i don't expect anyone to pay
my rent if you will in my light and my
phone and i'm willing to take personal
responsibility for my own well-being
that means my own physical well-being
and you sometimes show that by open
caring i'm willing to take personal
responsibility for protecting my family
and friends
and if anything
that's what open carrying a gun is meant
to do
but
firearms are tools and they break
anybody who's carried a firearm even the
best brand new firearms by the maker of
your choice they jam and they break
so most people consider carrying two
firearms
because one gun is really no gun and two
gun is one gun
and one just has to pay attention to the
local paper
they've had brand new cigs from the
state police they pull out to use in an
emergency situation
they don't go bank
so it's not unreasonable to carry
multiple firearms
but when you look at this bill
i see this bill as being ripe for abuse
you've got a couple problems whenever
you have vague terms
right for abuse
how many people have heard about people
getting swatted they call 9-1-1 and
report some fake activity next door
other people who don't like firearms
have claimed people just who are
carrying firearms have pointed a firearm
at them just to get them in trouble
and so to answer representative bert's
question unless these people are
actually carrying your body
i say the open carriers are subject to
get arrested and unless you have like a
50-foot coffin or something
you're gonna have trouble the people
attending your
wake no guns for them or at least no
open ones
but i think you need to look
specifically at the terms in this
particular bill and i think you look at
for example lawful marches what is a
lawful march
i don't know what a lawful march it's a
lawful march i see someone open carrying
and i don't like them all been carrying
so me and my friend start marching we've
got two of us we're having a lawful
march
and we can then say to the police arrest
these people they're within 100 foot of
us and we're having a lawful march
what's a vigil how many people have seen
people who have died or been killed and
you see a bunch of flowers by the road
or a bunch of flowers in town and
candles
and they'll have a nightly news thing
but is a vigil one person so if i'm
really sad because someone died and they
have the little flowers there and a
picture of them and a candle
i can have a vigil right
that means this hundred foot perimeter
no bugarian
and what if you just happen to be
walking down the street again right for
abuse these terms are not defined
who's a spectator
can i be a spectator of something that's
good distance away that means i'm
essentially a roving
no open carry zone
because i'm a spectator of that funeral
going on over there
so the thing is you've got to ask
yourself how could this be abused and i
think it could be abused 10 ways to
sunday
and we look at this
and we say
impromptu counter protest counter
rallies counter marches
what in the world are those
i don't know the answer
but
you don't have a right
not to have firearms around you i have a
right to carry firearms it's in the
constitution last time i read it
but you can show me just because
i'm intimidated by men in red shirts
i don't think representatives should get
to wear red shirts because that that
makes me feel uncomfortable
i mean where do we go with this
the bottom line is
nobody is saying that the people who are
carrying firearms openly are doing or
saying anything to make a reasonable
person
feel afraid there's laws for that
so i'm asking that this bill be itl for
many many reasons not the least of which
is quite frankly
it's really
a recipe for every anti-gunner in the
state
to intimidate and harass gun owners
and if that was their intention this is
the beautiful piece of legislation
because it's going to do that
it's what every
anti-firearm person could wish for
because it's like trying to say you
can't do anything within 150 feet of
anything
wherever you measure there's going to be
a visual wherever you measure there's
going to be a counter protest wherever
you
and you're going to have no chance
that's the other thing you're not going
to have you're not going to know what
hit you
so i'm happy to answer practical
questions but as i look at this
i don't think the other thing you might
want to look at is all the terms defined
in 6 25 11. if you look at new hampshire
rsa 625-11
which is a statute that talks about how
things are meant to be used
if i'm wearing some big long sharp
earrings that you say
that i could use them to poke with you
with
is that one of the things i can't carry
i have some of those cool hair sticks
that are pokey on the end
one of you guys don't like hair sticks
deadly weapon
so i respectfully say this needs to be
ideal for many many reasons
and happy to answer any questions
thank you the witness is excused
at this time when i'll close the public
hearing on house bill 1151.
uh
so this is a procedural
and i mean no disrespect i actually
once the
gavel hits them
the hearing's been closed like i don't
think we
it was pretty close i was trying to hold
up i'm not really sure
i'm sure i don't have one on this one in
the water
point of order
representative you're recognized for a
um the resident has traveled to the
capitol
i believe he intended to speak
and
and i would be interested to hear what
he has to say
thank you representative connolly
i thought that wasn't going on the
direction
is this if if the clerk does not find
the pink card can you just
please fill out another one
and you may you may testify in my my
apologies to the member of the public my
apologies if i put the wrong number on
uh this was the one that i definitely
came to speak for so thank you very much
um i appreciate that um david leroux so
where to start obviously this should be
in my opinion uh itld i guess is the
term for it
i want to read you a quote
we cannot but pity the boy who has never
fired a gun he is no more humane
while his education has been sadly
neglected anybody recognize that henry
david thoreau
1846 walden
okay
not wanting to use carry be involved
with firearms does not make you a more
uh humane ethical better person
okay we have heard lots of things based
on feelings we have heard the arguments
about how a firearm makes somebody feel
and the bottom line is your feelings i
don't believe their reference in the
constitution but i'm not a scholar
what i do know is we have a second
amendment now
why have i not heard anybody talk about
any actual data if we're looking for a
safer society let me give you 2020 fbi
data
now if i said is vermont a very safe
state most people would say yes but what
if you feel like vermont is not safe
enough for you you could move to idaho
they are safer per the 2020 fbi data
what if idaho is still too scary for
your feelings well you may move to maine
but what if maine is not good enough you
may move to new hampshire because
according to the 2020 fbi data
new hampshire ranks 50.
we are the safest for murder
we are 49 sadly for violent crime i know
it's terrible but if more people carried
firearms perhaps we could get to the
bottom of the barrel for violent crime
as well those are numbers those are not
feelings
now
i open carry i dislike concealed carry
i have spent my whole life since i have
been using firearms training with open
carry i was trained in the us coast
guard as what we call a boarding team
member our equivalent of coast guard
police as a federal law enforcement
officer
to open carry
cops open carry for a multiple of
reasons and i can uh talk about that we
have retention holsters it is at high a
hotly contested point that a holster
that is concealed typically does not
have a method of retention so if
somebody sees your firearm and wishes to
take it from you they can now just draw
that out because there is nothing in the
holster to physically hang on to that
typically most
open carry outside the hip holsters that
you would see on a pistol have a method
of retention some of them two or three
it's what's known as a triple retention
holster so a bad actor which we are
totally afraid of comes up to try to
take your firearm they now have to fight
to try to get the firearm not only from
you someone who has professed the experi
the expression that you are willing to
take responsibility for your life
because when seconds count the cops are
only minutes away and it has been shown
that the police are not obligated to put
themselves in harm's way
um that they now have to not only
contend with you but they have to try to
get the firearm out of your holster now
when i was trained as a coast guard law
enforcement member the one thing i was
told when we were carrying firearms
was that if somebody is trying to take
your firearm they intend to use it for
you so hanging on to your firearm is
literally the fight for your life
now we also have the fear of deadly
weapons
now if if somebody is killed with a
knife is that knife less deadly than a
firearm
we talk about the lethality lethality
was said well whatever kills somebody is
lethal
now what we were trained on in the coast
guard and this may be different now but
what i i remember and i still use is
called the use of force triangle this is
not just related to deadly force and
i'll define that in a second but it's
related to any use of force because
there are many levels of force as
anybody who supports police or has been
a policeman or does any self-defense
training will understand that there are
certain levels of force that are
applicable and appropriate for the
situation you are in
we'll also talk about what is
appropriate when you are carrying a
firearm versus when you're not
the use of force triangle as it stood
when i was in the military and trained
by the coast guard as a federal law
enforcement officer where multiple times
i stood over colombian drug smugglers
and migrants and people who occasionally
had fully automatic weapons and things
that we would confiscate doing drug
interdiction the use of force triangle
is three very simple parts
ability opportunity and intent
if somebody is 150 feet away from me and
they have a knife i don't care what
their intent is
i do not have a right to shoot them
because i am outside the effective range
of that weapon if somebody is carrying a
firearm they might be within range of
you but what is the intent do they have
the opportunity the ability if that
rifle such as i normally carry is slung
behind the back that is a very hard sell
to shoot them in the face because the
rifle is not able to be presented and is
not a physical threat they must bring
that weapon to bear we can talk about
how police are um
adjudicated on how their their process
goes when
they have a justified shooting these
things are evaluated
now we have rules and laws that cover
the feelings aspect where somebody feels
threatened by a firearm it's called
brandishing
okay it was mentioned if your shirt
pulls up and the handle of your firearm
is now exposed that could be considered
brandishing in other states there are
very specific rules and rsas already
covered just like any violent crime
against somebody who's afraid of the
guns any violent crime that the gun
carrier would enact upon that poor soul
they're already being able to be
prosecuted by law
now um
let's see we talked about new hampshire
we talked about use force differences in
training and draw time i prefer open
carry as i said that's the way i've
always trained okay
what is most important when using and
carrying a firearm is that you are
accurate you know your target you know
why and you can articulate that this was
justified because heavens forbid
somebody uses a firearm in a negligent
way i would never want that and that
must be the worst thing to be somebody
who takes another life out of uh you
know when it's not necessary
now it was mentioned written house it
was clear that he used self-defense when
he was physically being assaulted with a
skateboard
okay
that was decided
now it's also worth noting that the
criminals who were assaulting him who
were the victims well i hate i won't use
the word victim but who are the people
who got shot
i believe one was a pedophile and one
was a felon with a firearm
criminals don't believe in the law we do
now we're not only talking about you not
being able to have an event where you
can't prevent us or a gun owner an open
carrier from coming to your event um
we can't stop you from coming to an
event that's the nature of freedom now
you are free to have a no gun event of
course you are
you can rent a hall you can have a
private event you can have security you
can hire people and you cannot make it a
public event but a public space a public
event on the street where you do not
have an expectation of privacy and
there's nothing that says you have an
expectation to be a hundred feet away
from a firearm
that that's an unreasonable expectation
nobody would go for that
we've also equated owning guns or the
display of guns with crime as i
mentioned there is brandishing there are
actual crimes there's criminal
threatening if i threaten you
by mouth
while i'm in possession of a firearm yes
that's a much different thing
now
now really
this is not about the law because the
law is pretty clear i don't see how
anybody could read our constitution and
our laws and understand constitutional
carry and pass anything that looks
anything like this
i'd be liable to call you a treasonous
traitor to the constitution
that's the bottom line the second
amendment protects the first and i
guarantee you if there was some anti-gun
rally
and i was present or some other person
was present with a firearm and then
there was a person who actually started
to promote to enact violence against
those protesters the people with the
firearms would be the one to come to
your aid
we are addressing what is fundamentally
the nature of self-defense the nature of
the idea that you have a right to defend
yourself and your loved ones and as it
was stated if
the fear of something an inanimate
object
is allowed to be pushed as legislative a
powerful reason to make a legislation
like this what's
next you don't teach
a child who's afraid of black people
because they had a piss-poor upbringing
to stay away from black people because
they're really dangerous you teach them
not to be racist and to not hate
somebody based on an arbitrary standard
i could go on for days i'll take
questions
thank you for your testimony the witness
is excused
any members of the public president wish
to testify that have not testified
already
seeing none will now close the public
hearing on house bill 1151
this time we'll now open the executive
session on house bill 11 51
chair recognizes representative burke to
make a motion
thank you mr speaker mr chair and i'll
on house bill
1151 itl
has that been seconded by representative
wallace
representative berta we should speak to
the motion
yes uh thank you mr chairman
i just see so many problems in this bill
and you know really i guess
you know i don't even know where to
start other than on line 24 and 25. if i
or anybody's just traveling on page one
if anybody is traveling down the road
and there's a protest
you know they could get nabbed
now yes the first offense is a hundred
dollars but
each offense after that is a thousand
dollars
and i assure you if somebody saw john
burt driving by a
protest that is against guns they're
going to look and go oh he's within 100
you know 100 feet of us
and chances are he's carrying so they're
going to call the police on me and i can
see a lot of people getting trapped in
there
you know if you just go throughout the
bill
mr chairman there just seems to be
a lot of issues to entrap people and
that's why i am going to support
the itl thank you
representative rhodes you recognized
thank you mr chairman
i would just like to echo everything
that the last speaker miss larue said
thank you
representatives you're recognized
yes i want to be very clear
this bill
this bill is not about feelings
this bill is protecting
this bill is all about protecting
first amendment rights
they were
and i think if as you read the bill i
think it's very clear from the language
of the bill
that there was a great deal of care
taken in the drafting of this bill to
protect second amendment rights
the right to care the right to conceal
carry during protests and demonstrations
is in the bill if you want to bring a
weapon for self-defense to one of these
events you can do that
what this bill is expressly intended to
do
is to prevent situations where people
bring firearms to protests to
demonstrations to rallies
and
make them and essentially display them
in a way that intimidates others it's
exactly what representative all chiller
was talking about when she was talking
about coercive control that's exactly
what it is
when you show up when you have a
especially when you have a group of
people who show up at somebody else's
demonstration
carrying firearms it sends a message and
the message is
knuckle under or else
and that's totally unacceptable
this is a democracy
and it just
makes me incredibly sad that we've
gotten to a point in this country
where we don't
seem to understand
anymore
what we have to protect
i mean we're going through a period of
incredible
division and divisiveness i think
everybody knows that right now it's not
easy for anybody
and and i think one of the literally one
of the worst things that we can do
is
to essentially
legitimize the
care the open carrying of firearms
at public demonstrations
and i think we've seen repeatedly over
the especially over the last couple of
years how when that happens when that is
allowed to happen it basically turns
these
uh these events that that are already uh
in danger of erupting into violence it
it basically becomes the match that
lights the powder the tin the tinderbox
and it's totally unacceptable
um
i
i i fear for new hampshire going forward
if we don't have uh if we don't have
laws like this
because it's important for people to be
able to
express express themselves without fear
of intimidation that that's really kind
of what our democracy is all about
um and this whole argument
that uh that that somehow
we're the ones who are in fear is
uh is basically total bs
you know what about the people who feel
like they can't go to a protest without
bringing a firearm
especially peaceful protests
it's
it's sickening and i urge you to reject
those arguments
and i urge uh
i urge you to also reject
the an expedient to legislate uh
recommendation thank you
and i'm just gonna clear this is just a
clarification criminal threatening is
already illegal
it's codified under new hampshire law
and that's rsa 6
631 colon 4. and if you review that
there is an enhanced penalty if you
threaten someone with
a deadly weapon which would obviously
include a firearm so any
under new hampshire's existing law it's
already illegal to threaten someone
with a firearm it's actually a class b
felony
already
representative roy you're recognized
thank you mr chairman
um
i would just as far as um these this
notion of these
peaceful protests goes
i amongst other people watched many of
our major cities burn last year
that started out as peaceful protest we
watched entire sections of major cities
in this country be annexed
by terrorists and held
in some kind of their own i don't know
zone or something that they did
and and
nothing could be more peaceful than a
christmas parade where i watched a bunch
of children get mowed down by a vehicle
so this whole notion of peaceful protest
i think is suspect at best
i think that the person's right to
self-defense does indeed trump their uh
the ability to to be able to hold a
peaceful protest when when you have no
evidence that these protests remain
peaceful
at this time to met
representative klein knight you're
recognized
thank you chair
thank you members
for listening to all the testimony and
members of the public for coming in and
peacefully
exercising your first amendment right
without the need to uh
brandish anything as it were
and um
it was very nice and peaceful good
conversation
but that being said and penalties
already existing that's all well and
good but
all it takes is one man with an ak-47 to
wipe out hundreds of people we've seen
it in concerts we've seen it in
you know we've just seen it in movie
theaters we've seen it
in so many public spaces
and yes it you do have a right to
protection
but you know an eye for an eye and
one gun just to cancel out another gun
just to cancel out it's just gonna bring
it's it i don't
i really don't understand why you need
something of such violence and
destruction in a peaceful place to
co-exist
unless you are looking to intimidate
somebody or take something by force
like the january 6
insurrection
this set
remember his freak will be recognized if
he wishes to speak
thank you mr chairman um
you know i am
i think that the sponsor deserves a lot
of credit for bringing forward this bill
it's a subject that is hard to have a
rational debate around where people can
express themselves
without passions getting inflamed it's
very hard to do
um i don't like
when i see people out and about open
carrying i don't understand it
i don't think it's necessary
i don't really think it's necessary to
carry a gun anywhere but that is my own
personal thought
um
unfortunately the law in this state
unfortunately as i see it the law in the
state is that one is allowed to carry a
gun
outwardly openly and
i would rather those laws be changed
rather than a piecemeal approach so i'll
be supporting the itl
representative newman
i just want to comment that
i believe that there are peaceful
protests
and i believe that the first amendment
allows for the petition of the
government and i assume that our
forefathers at that time thought that
there would be peaceful protests and i
still still think
that there's a lot of peaceful protests
however i don't think that the
what happened at the capitol was a
peaceful protest
so i'm
i think people can be
intimidated by open carry and i'm not
going to split i'm not going to support
the itl motion
this time the matter will now be put to
question if you in support of the motion
of inexpedient to legislate please say
yay if you were opposed
please say nay the clerk will now call
the roll
vice chairman roy
yes
representative welch
yes representative burt
yes representative rhodes
yes representative greene yes clerk
votes yes representative testament yes
representative true
yes
representative pratt
yes representative marston
yes
representative harriet gathright no
representative pantalakis no
representative o'hearn representative
bordenay
yes
representative muse
no
representative newman
representative bolden
representative conley
representative klein knight
no
representative bradley no
chairman abbas
the chair votes yes
12 years
six nays two not voting
there's 12 yes
i had 13.
okay
it's thirteen to six the vote the motion
passes
representative you'll be preparing a
majority report
yes mr chairman there'll be a majority
report and i'm assuming this won't go on
consent
will it be a minority report
representative gatherer will prepare a
minority report representative
thank you mr chair just for my record
what was the count 13-6 and two not
voting
that's correct
at this time you'll now close the
executive session on house bill 1151
this time we'll now open the public
hearing on house bill 1096 prohibiting
open carrying or display of a deadly
weapon within
100 feet of a polling place
this time the chair recognizes
representative muse to introduce
house bill 1096.
and we are running behind schedule with
the exception of the representative
that's going to introduce the bill
i'm going to limit the public testimony
to two minutes per per member of the
public
representative true would you mind being
the
time keeper
representative you may begin
i'm sorry mr chair do i have a time
limit
you you do not have a time limit but for
the
after after the bill's introduced the
remaining members are of the public who
testify will have two minutes
time on it
thank you much
let me start by saying that in this
country no american should ever be
threatened with guns either explicitly
or implicitly
while simply exercising their right to
vote
intimidation including intimidation by
armed civilians has long been a tool
that some have used to prevent full
participation in american democracy
during and after reconstruction guns
were often used to scare black voters
away from the polls
that history of armed voter intimidation
is not a distant memory
guns of the poles are a tinderbox near
an open flame
in manchester during the november 2020
election an armed man harassed people
holding signs for candidates in the
election earring area outside three
separate polling places in charlotte
north carolina an iron man was arrested
after a polling supervisor asked him to
leave a polling place on election day
and he returned
in lane county oregon armed individuals
reportedly approached people as they
were dropping off their ballots
since the last election cycle
misinformation and questionable claims
of voter fraud and election rigging have
resulted in armed protesters showing up
during recounts in places like arizona
passions in this fall's elections are
likely to run equally high or higher
i'm introducing hb 10 1096 today as a
proactive attempt to make our election
safer for all of our citizens this bill
would prohibit open carrying or display
of a deadly weapon within 100 feet of a
polling place on the days where federal
state and or municipal elections are
taking place
what this bill does not do is eliminate
the right to self-defense
there are exceptions for voters and
election officials legally carrying
concealed weapons
there are also exceptions for law
enforcement officials and pickup truck
owners with shotguns or rifles secured
and gun racks because this is new
hampshire and people do come into
parking lots of schools with pickup
trucks with gun racks with rifles in
them
what this bill does not
what this bill does is it is modify new
hampshire's voter intimidation statute
that's rsa 629
it also requires that notices be posted
letting people know
that this that this law is in effect
there are also exceptions
i'm sorry
six states in the district of columbia
have already explicitly
prohibited guns in polling places
and this bill is needed because under
current law state and local authorities
can't prevent people from bringing guns
into polling places even those located
in school buildings
as an open carry state new hampshire
allows gun owners to openly carry a
loaded firearm onto public property
without a license or a permit
and since 2017 the state has also
allowed any lawful gun owner to carry a
concealed weapon without a license
with hp 1096 we have the power
to fix a problem in our election law and
we also have the constitutional
authority to do it
the supreme court of the united states
said it best when they reasoned in
westbury versus sanders that no right is
more precious in a free country than
having a voice in the election of those
who make the laws under which is good
citizens we must live
other rights even the most basic are
illusory
if the right to vote is undermined
however the fundamental right to vote
without fear of intimidation
vital to our democracy is in is
endangered when we allow deadly weapons
to be displayed as an implicit threat to
others inside and outside our polling
places
in the heller decision
justice antonin scalia wrote that while
the second amendment protects the right
of law-abiding responsible citizens to
use arms and defense of hearth and home
he also wrote that nothing in our
opinion should be taken to cast doubt on
long-standing prohibitions on laws
forbidding the carrying of firearms in
sensitive places such as schools and
government buildings
several states including georgia have
already interpreted sensitive places to
include polling places
polling places are public areas they are
used for the purpose of facilitating
elections that are vital to our
democracy
for fans of american history it's also
worth pointing out
that the very same generation that added
the second amendment to the constitution
also passed state laws prohibiting
bringing guns to the polls
for example
the 1776 delaware state constitution
provides that no person shall come armed
to any of them and that no muster of
militia shall be made on that day
it further provided that no battalion or
company could come within a mile of the
polling place for 24 hours before or
after an election
to prevent violence or force to be used
at set elections
the same year maryland passed a nearly
identical resolution
new york followed suit a decade later
and more and more states added similar
laws during reconstruction in the early
20th century
hb 1096 is not an anti-gun law as some
would frame it
but instead it's a pro-voter law that
will lower the risk of armed
intimidation happening in a place where
it should absolutely never happen
keep in mind that if this bill passes is
written
voters and election officials will
continue to be able to carry concealed
weapons to polling places for
self-defense
the right to self-defense is protected
under this bill
the right to vote without intimidation
is also protected which is extremely
important
and this will leave it up to new
hampshire voters to do what new
hampshire voters do best
to choose the best candidates possible
without the chilling effect of armed
intimidation
i asked the committee to give this bill
an ought to pass recommendation
thank you
thank you representative
uh representative klein knight you were
recognized
thank you chair
um thank you representative muse for
taking my question
um where
are most polling places located at
i'm sorry i'm sorry you have to get a
little closer to the microphone
where are most polling places in our
state located at what kind of property
i believe the members asking where are
most polling places located what type of
property
most polling places are located in
schools and public buildings
libraries
some are located in church halls as well
represent klein knight you recognize for
a follow-up
usually in these um peaceful buildings
is there a need for
brandishing or showing off
um a firearm or a weapon
or
especially in front of children
okay
i just said um usually in those kinds of
buildings especially whether
children would you really need do you
feel you would really need
to flash a weapon
i'm not sure if it's the particular
microphone in front of the
representative but
representatives do you mind repeating
the question before you if that's
i don't mean to put the put you in an
unfair position
i i believe the
i believe the the
the question was is
whether or not there were children uh
who were in those buildings at the time
no i'm sorry
this microphone works
so an answer to what i think i think was
your question
yes there are some schools i know in
ward 5 and portsmouth
during during national and state
elections
children are actually have a day off
from school during municipal elections
they are actually in school during
voting
during the voting process
thank you representative
you for your testimony the
representative is excused
the committee now calls representative
greg huff
thank you mr chairman and members
honorable members of the criminal
justice and public safety committee
i stand in opposition of this bill
and i ask that you uh
committed to inexpedient to legislate
this bill is uh basically part two of
the last bill it just adds one more
constraint
there's nothing new to see here
it's it's bad legislation and it should
not continue
and i'll leave you for the last time
today
my third appearance
article 2a of the new hampshire
constitution the bearing of arms all
persons have the right to keep and bear
arms in defense of themselves their
families their property and the state um
and
if you need to check that i'm sure
everybody has a copy of the constitution
i'll take any questions
thank you for your testimony thank you
chairman
committee now calls russian chester
thank you thank you for allowing me to
speak today just want to talk a little
bit about bottom line is this is
discrimination bottom line absolute
discrimination the fact that
um
i was identified as someone who has an
arsenal because i mentioned earlier that
i owned more than one gun or that i had
applied for more than one gun for the
record my first gun was a hunting rifle
that i learned to hunt with with my
father when i was very young my second
gun became a concealed carry um
well a second gun became a
pistol and the reason for that is
because during a
mostly peaceful protest
in
2016 i was physically attacked with a
sign poll
and i made the decision that day
that i would rather die
protecting my life than die a victim
so the bottom line here is this again
speaks to that sign poll was no
different than the sign polls that folks
have as you're walking into the election
arena additionally if we're talking
about chilling let's talk about the
number of one party or the other that
happens to be at some of these polling
places intimidating and coercing people
to sign up or by giving away free things
or uh you know they've got 23 signs to
your one side and they're not allowed as
far as i know in my area they're not
allowed to approach you or
continue to run for any kind of
political office during that time
but i can honestly tell you that they
are very intimidating and they do
make you feel uncomfortable
am i saying that they can't be there
anymore because if this guilt bill gets
passed then we will expect to see that
there can be no
solicitation or polling at any polling
place
thank you and i'll take any questions of
here
thank you for your testimony the witness
is
excused the committee now calls david
larue
come on david larue um everything i said
last time plus i personally voted last
year wearing a firearm in my town hall
not a school not a library not a place
with little kids we voted in our town
hall and i will tell you i'm sure i was
not the only one with a firearm but i
might have been the only one open
carrying because as i said i train open
carry that's the way i'm most proficient
that is the way i'm most able to
accurately self-defend myself um again
we have this concept that the mere
presence of a firearm is a threat again
reference criminal threatening
brandishing issues getting in somebody's
face the way you conduct yourself
when you carry a firearm if you're smart
not necessarily if you're a responsible
gun owner if you smart you conduct
yourself differently when you have a
firearm you cannot afford to get into a
pissing contest with somebody over a
difference of opinion because you now
have a firearm with you which as we know
aggravates crimes under the law
so we already have covered this whole
dangerous firearm thing
we also have this idea that somehow the
firearm is intimidating people which
direction is the fire intimidating
people to vote because as i understand
it we're not allowed to wear a political
shirt when i go in to vote i can't have
on a hillary clinton shirt when i go to
cast my vote
they won't allow it i know people this
last election who were told to change
their clothing because you can't do that
so if you're not allowed to wear or
display anything that says
how you're voting how are you
intimidating somebody again it's the
mere presence of a physical inanimate
object that is the reason why this is
being pushed um
you know and then the last thing is if
we are to follow the train because i
will use any logic you wish i will
debate any logic you wish with your
logic that the mere presence of the
firearm is threatening and coercive in
intimidation what about the cops
what about state police chilling of
rights chilling of free speech
anybody at the executive council
anybody ever had a cop right up in your
face cops are allowed under all these
bills the state is allowed to intimidate
and uh coerce and threaten just with the
mere presence of a firearm
i don't agree that that's the premise
but if that's the logic that flies
your two minutes is up thank you
thank you sir for your testimony
once again the honorable joe hannon the
witness is excused
hello joe hannan from gun owners of new
hampshire and uh thank you for listening
to me today
um like it's been said this has been a
lot of the same points as a previous
bill but a lot of the words are still
the same problem officers on duty does
that mean not off-duty pickup truck like
i mentioned there are priuses out there
with gun racks
but it also means if someone has
something in their car they can't remove
it from their rack and put in their
trunk if they're in a neighborhood they
might not feel safe leaving it in a
visible position so someone can't even
take it off of a gun rack and lock it
somewhere else in the vehicle if they're
parked in a bad area not a lot of them
in new hampshire but there are a few um
you know there's a lot of people who are
unable to easily carry concealed this
allows for concealed carry at poles but
usually it's pretty cold and people are
wearing jackets so if i go into a
polling place i can't take my coat off
i'll be i'll be all right i'll be a
little sweaty for a while but what if
someone goes in that's unable to handle
the heat for 20 30 minutes and passes
out you know that's not really a good
situation to be in someone shouldn't
have to dictate their dress code by
other people's emotions and if that's
the case we can go through a whole list
of laws that should be on the books
which i don't think should be as far as
dress code
last thing i'd like to say is
brandishing has been thrown around a lot
is you know something that's a problem
the word brandishing does not appear
anywhere in new hampshire
rsas it just doesn't exist
uh there are some states that use the
word brandishing uh as a specific
prohibited prohibited act and you know
most of those places describe it as
waving or
especially something usually a weapon in
a threatening
in a threatening manner in anger or
excitement
just holding something even according to
that definition or having it on their
person openly would not be brandishing
in any way so um
you know we also passed a bill last year
that said that just the mere display of
a firearm is not threat criminal
threatening and that was clarified and i
believe another i won't mention the bill
but it was last year it was passed and
signed so
anyway that's it i'd be happy to take
any questions
thank you for your testimony the chair
may inquire with the question
uh so my understanding that this bill it
creates uh it would create a restriction
with an open carrying with 100 feet of a
polling place
so
would that apply to a person who's on
their own private property this happens
to be within 100 feet of a polling place
uh it doesn't have an exception and also
uh my polling place i know know it very
well because i ran there and held signs
and electioneering isn't allowed within
100 feet and people had to stand pretty
close to the entrance some places the
100 feet may preclude the entrance to a
polling place they might not be even
allowed to go into the polling place
with their vehicle they may have to go
home out of their way or be unable to
vote that day and could theoretically be
disenfranchised because they couldn't go
into the parking lot let alone the place
itself even if they did lock it up in
their car
just by being in their vehicle open
carry they have to like hide it or they
pull in and then not let anyone see them
put in their trunk
so
thank you
all good this time the witness is
excused thank you for your testimony
the committee now calls alan rice gun
owners of america
good afternoon members of the committee
mr chairman once again for the record my
name is alan rice and i am a resident of
bedford new hampshire
and i am here representing gun owners of
america national organization
all this talk about not being able to
carry a gun in the open makes you want
to carry a gun in the open i usually
carry a gun concealed
for personal safety
but i'm going to have to reconsider that
i have to reconsider that i wanted to
expand on something that was said on the
previous bill because i think it's on
point
uh this coercive control
to me is a fancy word basically to say
i'm too chicken and i don't trust
anybody and i have no way to take and
i'm unwilling to take responsibility for
my personal safety
um that that just it's just way out of
step with new hampshire values
um i'm not going to take the full two
minutes um because most of the points
are the same as i made on a previous
bill and i would ask the committee to
vote this bill in expedient to legislate
thank you the witness is excused
the committee now calls penny dean
thank you members of the committee for
hearing my name is penny dean a resident
of concord new hampshire
and i respectfully ask that you itl this
bad bill
i would ask you look at rsa 659 43 roman
3 which is referenced
in roman one of the bill
and that allows the moderators shall
designate a preferred area for
electioneering and it goes on and on and
on
so what can happen and what likely would
happen is the actual area would be more
than a hundred feet
circumference from the actual polling
place
the statute or the bill also proposes
that this be all day even if the polling
is only part of the day
so a person will think well gee the
polling is only going on from noon to
eight
this only applies then we'll know it
applies the whole day
there's a lot of what i call tricky
things but i think the most important
thing for those who don't carry a
firearm every day and don't take
responsibility for their own
self-defense and personal protection
i want the taxpayers to foot that
people do not deliberately quote unquote
bring a gun to the polls
when i get up in the morning and get
dressed and i put on my guns
i put them on just like i put on my bra
and skivvies and i take them off at
night so i'm not quote unquote bringing
them anywhere they're already with me
because just like if i knew which day i
was going to get in a car accident i'd
stay home that day be real simple
same day if i knew which day i was going
to get attacked by some bad person i
wouldn't go out that day but i don't
know that
and so people are not quote-unquote
bringing their guns anywhere most people
that take responsibility for their own
self-defense have their gun with them
and the polling place is no different
you don't know if when you leave the
polling place
if you're going to have a problem and
quite frankly the other point which i
think another speaker made which is
really good i was half my size before my
injuries i was a distance runner
unfortunately now i still have some
injuries and i'm a much bigger girl and
i can tell you that carrying
carrying firearms now more likely to be
open because they don't fit the way they
used to
thank you and i'm happy to answer any
questions
thank you for your testimony
the witness is excused
any members of the public who wish to
testify have that who have not testified
already
at this time we will now close the
public hearing on house bill 1096.
at this time we'll now open the
executive session house bill 1096.
representative burke do you wish to be
recognized
yes mr chairman i would like to make a
motion on house bill 1096 itl and
expedient to legislate
the motion of innix being into legislate
that has been seconded by representative
roy
representative
do you wish to speak to your motion yes
please
thank you mr chairman
there are several things
well like the last speaker said
and she said it very well
there's a lot of tricky things in this
bill
and one of them is
my poland place bartlett elementary in
goffstown which has been there over 100
years now
is within a hundred feet of the road
so again i go back to i am driving by
the school
and at that point i am in violation of
this
law this bill if it became law
there's just again many things that
they're trying to address a problem that
doesn't exist
i've seen
several people open carry
at the polling place i myself open carry
every time i vote
i'm not the only one in that building
doing it
every policeman there's open carrying
and a lot of the voters are also open
carrying
i don't see any intimidation toward
anybody forcing them to vote one way or
another because i can't wear a
particular
political shirt that i wish to wear
they're very strict on that
so i just don't see where this bill is
going to fix anything
other than they're looking for a problem
that doesn't exist thank you mr chairman
representative muse you're recognized
so if we don't pass this bill
we put one more gauntlet in front of the
average person
who wants to go to the polls uh to take
advantage of
something that every american has the
right to take advantage in the due and
that's to vote for the candidates of
their choice
without fear of intimidation
again we are not saying that people have
to go to the polls defenseless
this bill does allow for people
for poll workers and for voters
to uh
to bring concealed weapons into the
polls what this what this bill tries to
specifically address
is the open carrying and display of
weapons outside polling places which has
become a real problem
this is not a made up thing this is not
not a made up problem these incidents
are real and they've been happening
across the country
and again
given the level of division that we're
going through right now given the way
that so many people are questioned
questioning the integrity of our
elections questioning the integrity of
the voting process the bills that we've
seen uh demanding that uh
that that that people uh uh be
you'll be allowed to uh to stand close
to election workers um and and monitor
results um we even had one i think where
people are going to be allowed i guess
to do that now uh in
in candidate and campaign regalia
the the issue is it is one thing to
express yourself
it's it's another thing
completely
to do it in a way that's that's
intimidating to other people
coming to the polls to vote should be a
liberating experience for every american
it should be the
you know one of the things that we're
proudest to do it's one of our biggest
responsibilities as citizens the polls
should be an inviting and welcoming
place
not a place where people have to go
to run a gauntlet of other people with
with firearms
again
you know we are not talking about taking
away anybody's second amendment rights
with this bill what we're basically
saying is keep the weapons in your pants
people
um
i urge you to uh
to reject the
inexpedient to legislate recommendation
and
so we could take a vote and
pass this bill thank you
representative true
thank you mr chair
it was pointed out by by somebody in
testimony and i'll repeat the point
that
if if i'm standing within a hundred feet
of a polling place
i am intimidating somebody
well if i'm just standing there
with a with a gun on my hip
who would i be intimidating i
i don't know how you're going to vote
i don't know which candidate you're not
you're not going to support my candidate
i don't know any of that
i'm just standing there
i'm not intimidating somebody
to vote one way or the other
that
that's that's not possible
what i see here today
is a disconnect and i think it's a
disconnect
not only in this hall but in this
country
that
there is a second amendment
that grants
u.s citizens rights
and a lot of people don't like those
rights
however
somebody can't say that my
i don't believe
somebody should be allowed to say
that my second amendment must be
curtailed
because of the way they feel
and that's what i think this is it's
they they they want to take away they
don't want to take away the policeman's
right so it's not really the gun that
they're afraid of right the the town
policeman standing there maybe two of
them
they're walking the gauntlet through the
police when they get to the polls
they're not taking away their right they
want to take away
my right just to peacefully carry and
that's the that's the disconnect
and
and maybe the disconnect will be here
for many many years but
that's all mr chair thank you
this time the matter will now be put to
question
if you are in support of the motion of
any speeding to legislate please say yay
if you're opposed please say nay the
clerk will now call the roll
vice chairman roy yes
representative welch
yes representative burt
yes representative rhodes
yes
representative greene
clark votes yes representative testament
yes
representative true yay
representative pratt yes
representative marston
yay
representative harriet gathright
no
representative pantalakas no
representative o'hearn
representative ordnae
yes
representative muse
no
representative newman
representative bolden
no
representative conley
yes
representative klein knight
no
representative bradley no
chairman abbas
the chair votes yes
okay
13 years seven days one not voting
motion of an exp to legislative passes
representative burke will you be
preparing a majority report
yes i will mr chairman thank you
would it be a minority report
and this time we'll now close the
executive session on house bill 1096.
at this time we are now open the public
hearing on house bill
1281. recognizes representative roy to
introduce house bill 1281
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee
um since introducing this bill i've had
conversations with several of the gun
groups advocates as well as domestic
violence advocates
and i decided that the bill
while its concept is still
worthy of support
it does need a little work so i'm going
to ask the committee to support a
recommendation of interim study
and i will not take any questions
thank you representative you are excused
if there's any members of the public
present who wish to testify um
please step forward
johan wave off joe
okay
stephen andres waves off attorney dean
this time we recognize
penny dean
representative klein knight
do you have a parliamentary inquiry
your microphone is
did you already
i recommend using representative
bradley's uh microphone
i'm sorry we're taking witnesses
question for the chair so sorry
you recognized for a parliamentary
inquiry
um are we listening to testimony now
that even though this uh prime sponsor
moved to interim study
yes any member of the public who's here
who came here to testify who still
wishes to testify will give them the
courage she as allowing them to do so
okay thank you
thank you chairman and members of health
attorney penny dean
in support of hb 1281
i think this bill is badly needed
the only
criticism i have which is actually rare
normally i have criticism of bills this
bill was actually pretty darn detailed
and so i'm puzzled as to why it's being
pulled the only
amendment i would have respectfully
suggested
is
the person being guilty of a felony
and in line
12 a person who's taking these firearms
is taking on a lot of responsibility and
this method is really good and this is
good drafting actually most of that's
good drafting and so i'd respectfully
say that maybe a small amendment
but rarely do i see gun bills this good
so
so that that's my only thing is i think
this bill is desperately needed people
in domestic situations they sometimes
need to sell their firearms to be able
to pay on going legal fees or personal
expenses when they leave their primary
home and they now have to rent another
home so i think the bill is a wonderful
idea it's timely it's been needed for
decades
and respectfully suggest whenever it's
ready to be put back out
that this concept i mean i can't speak
proactively to new language but this
concept is desperately needed
thank you for your testimony the witness
is excused
representative bourdain you recognize
for parliamentary inquiry
well
first they would have to we would have
to close the public hearing
and then we have to open an executive
session
which i intend to do right after i close
the public hearing
and i will likely be recognizing
representative roy to make a motion of
an interim study
that provide that motion is seconded
it would mean that we're not going to
take any action on the bill
this year however
it would be something that could be
further investigated down the line
at this time we will now close the
public hearing on
house bill
12 1281.
this time we'll now open the executive
session on house bill 1281
and
the chair will recognize representative
rory to make a motion
i would like to move interim study on hp
second has been seconded by
representative point of order
representative
i'm trying to i'm trying to recognize
you for your point of order please state
your point of order and just a friendly
reminder the microphone that you're
speaking into seems to be malfunctioning
so use the one to your left
um in mason's rules um point of order on
the right in executive session to debate
before making a motion
by me moving the question
do you mind restating your point of
order
as i've been looking through this lovely
book of mason's manual of legislative
procedures i did happen to glance at a
rule that says the body is entitled to
debate and healthy discussion in an
executive
session before
moving
right to a vote
that is a correct uh
reading and application of the rules i
will say that
the question has not been moved yet the
motion was made it was seconded and then
i opened it i was going to open up for
discussion so absolutely when it's
opened up for discussion uh the rule is
generally each member who wishes to
participate in the discussion may
participate at least one time when it's
opened
it's within the discretion that you had
to recognize a member a second time
however that's provided all the members
who have not spoke already
have been recognized to speak
thank you so much and your patience for
teaching me mr chair
that was that motion was seconded by
representative wallace
so
representative roy do you wish to speak
to the motion of interim study
thank you mr chairman as i stated when i
introduced the bill the uh the the
concept of the bill i i still support
and stand by there are just some minor
tweaks that need to be made to it and in
the interest of our full calendar this
year
that we will be limited on time and
sending it to the senate and it needs
some work so i'm just going to go ahead
and as i said recommend we hold on to it
klein knight you were recognized thank
you so much for recognizing me and again
apologies on that incorrect um
i jumped the gun there because this is
exactly what i wanted no need to
apologize it was a correct point of
order raised in a proper manner with the
exception of you talking over me but
otherwise it was okay well
thank you again and all i wanted to say
for the record was that
um i wanted to recognize uh
representative
roy's decision to
interim study this it's greatly
appreciated especially for
domestic and abuse survivors in the
state
it just needs a little bit more work but
i do
wonder why we can't move to itl and vote
down this interim study so another
motion can be made such as that because
it could be brought up again in the next
term
representative newman you were
recognized
based on that
excellent point of order i have a
parliamentary inquiry as to
what is the effect of
the
interim study this year given our
accelerated calendar does that just mean
it could come up next year does it mean
it could come up in this session or
how how does that work
if i recall and last term was my first
term as i believe it was
your first term
when they were we had a we had a single
hearing where we discussed all the bills
that were
interim studied in in that
when we voted on each of those bills the
recommendation was
do we believe further legislation is
necessary in the future or not
so
this is something that as a committee we
would if and this would be
more closer to the fall
would we make a recommendation that
this be discussed
in the future
as opposed to not and that's that's what
the conversation would be
uh index being to legislate is simply a
negative recommendation
and thank you for your excellent
response to a parliamentary inquiry
at this time the matter will now be put
to put the question
if you were in support of the motion for
interim study please say yay if you are
opposed please say nay the clerk will
now call the roll
vice chairman roy yes
representative welch yes representative
burt yes
representative rhodes yes
representative greene yes
clerk votes yes representative testament
representative true yay
representative pratt
yes
representative marston
representative harriet gathright
no
representative panalakas
representative o'hearn
representative ordnae
representative muse
no
representative newman
representative bolden no
representative conley
representative klein knight no
representative bradley no
chairman abbas
the chair of ocs
with 12 eas
eight nays and one not voting the bill
is interim study
the motion passes
senator burt will you be making a
majority report
uh would representative rory be doing
that
oh my my confusion
you
you're recognized for your point of
order please state your point of order
are you sure it's not a parliamentary
inquiry
doesn't does an
uh interim study require
a report it would go to nobody would it
i think a requirement required is not
it's not required it's it's usually
recommended in the practice
as would a
majority minority report
would there be a minority report
at this time we'll now close
the exec the executive session on house
bill
and the committee will be
will be adjourned
was everyone going home
i look forward
you